[Musique]
Ran Branco, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Syerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? R Bronco vivant
pour commencer, heureux et ému d'être
d'être ici, avocat et notamment avocat
en ce moment de victime palestinienne à
la Cour pénale internationale. On est 10
dans le monde et on est moins qu'il y a
un an à cause des menaces et sanctions
qui sont en train de s'appliquer sur
chacun d'entre nous, mais aussi les
juges et les avocats, pardon, et les
procureurs et euh et par ailleurs engagé
sur un certain nombre de fronts qui euh
visiblement contribue à à me mettre en
danger et à nous mettre collectivement
en danger également.
On vous reçoit aujourd'hui
exceptionnellement. On était pas censé
être là mais on a remis le couvert parce
que c'était important d'avoir un débrief
de ce qui vous est arrivé. On vous a
reçu 3 jours plus tard, vous étiez à
l'hôpital. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
résumer, nous donner plus
d'informations, vous donner votre
interprétation et l'interprétation
peut-être médicale ? Je vous écoute.
Je suis parti à à Kinshasa au Congo.
Alors,
c'est très important peut-être que je
vous dise quelques mots sur la situation
là-bas. Il y a un conflit qui s'étend
depuis maintenant près de 40 ans entre
le Rwanda et la République démocratique
du Congo. Faut savoir que le la RDC est
un pays qui fait quasiment la taille de
l'Union européenne et le Ronda est un
pays beaucoup plus petit qui est dirigé
d'une main de fer par un homme qui
s'appelle Paul Kagamé qui dirigeait les
forces Tutsi qui ont gagné en 1994
contre le gouvernement Utou qui était en
train de commettre un génocide. Il y a
des forces alliées au gouvernement Outou
et une grande partie du gouvernement
Outou qui se sont exilés de l'autre côté
de la frontière. et qui ont créé un
certain nombre de milices pour continuer
la guerre contre Paul Kagamé. ce qui
sert à cet homme de prétexte pour
continuer à mettre en œuvre des
incursions dans l'est de la RDC pour au
prétexte donc de lutter contre ces
ministres en réalité pour se saisir d'un
certain nombre de mines notamment celle
de Roubaya qui est la plus importante
mine de Coltan euh et le Coltan est un
composant fondamental pour l'industrie
électronique et de télécommunication
euh et euh 70 % des réserves se trouvent
dans cette région. Et donc en réalité en
quelques semaines d'arrêt
d'exploitation, on pourrait mettre à bas
toute la chaîne
de de valeur et donc d'élaboration de
construction de vente de des téléphones,
des ordinateurs que l'on que l'on
consomme. C'est vraiment un lieu
stratégique et de façon générale, il
faut imaginer que la RDC donc qui est un
pays immense est aussi l'un des plus
pauvres au monde de sorte que la
capitale qui est complètement à l'ouest
n'arrive pas à être en contact direct et
à provisionner ces forces militaires qui
sont sur le front à l'est. Et donc, il y
a eu des millions de morts ces 40
dernières années du fait de ce conflit.
Et euh j'ai je m'étais rendu à Kinshasa
pour assister des victimes. Je devais me
rendre à Kinshasa pour assister des
victimes de ce conflit qui ont été euh
rapatriés pour être traité et pour
rencontrer un certain nombre d'instances
qui euh et d'associations qui s'en
occupent notamment la Commission
nationale des droits de l'homme. J'avais
été et ça c'est un point qui est qui est
assez peu connu. J'avais passé un mois
sur la zone de conflit. Il y a au moment
où le groupe armé qui aujourd'hui a pris
le contrôle sur tout l'est du Congo, le
M23 venait d'être créé. Donc c'était en
2012, c'était après la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 et j'avais passé
un mois sur les collines du Massissi.
Alors c'est très étonnant parce que ça
ressemble au à la Suisse, c'est des
collines verdoyantes. C'est pas du tout
l'image qu'on qu'on pourrait s'en faire.
et donc sur le chemin de cette milice
qui avait été créée par le Rwanda pour
cacher le fait que c'est le Rwanda qui a
pris pied au Congo et que donc il y a
une violation des frontières et donc une
guerre qui est menée contre les
autorités euh congolaises. Il y a des
gens qui confirment cette lecture, il y
a des institutions, des instances
internationales. Là, je voulais
présenter de la façon la plus neutre
possible. Le Rwanda conteste être
impliqué dans dans le conflit. En
réalité
le M23 qui euh euh n'est qu'une
extension des forces armées rwandaises
qui prend appui sur des Congolais mais
qui ne pourrait pas exister et prendre
cette ampleur territoriale sans le
soutien des forces spéciales rondaises
qui sont en première ligne et qui sont
celles qui ont réussi à prendre
notamment la capitale du nord Kivou,
Goma Bouavou ce qui est assez nouveau du
sud Kivou. Et en réalité ce qui est en
train de tenter de faire le ronda et ça
c'est intéressant c'est qu'ils sont en
train d'essayer de provoquer un coup
d'état à Kinshasa. Donc ils ont récupéré
l'ancien président Joseph Kabila qui a
été qui est le fils de Laurent Désiré
Kabila. Je vais peut-être pas vous
refaire toute l'histoire du conflit mais
ça serait intéressant. euh Laurent Desir
Kabila qui en fait dans la suite de du
génocide rwandais partant du Rwanda avec
l'appui aussi de de l'Ouganda euh fait
un rail un raid sur pardon euh sur
Kinshasa et prend le pouvoir. C'est
documenté tout ça ? Tout ça c'est
documenté. Oui, c'est vraiment
l'histoire officielle. Quelques années
plus tard, il meurt 4 ans plus tard et
son fils qui a 27 ans prend prend le
pouvoir ce ce phénomé général et va
rester au pouvoir pendant près de 15 ans
avant de le quitter dans le cas d'un
arrangement avec le président actuel. Et
donc cet ancien président qui avait
quitté le pouvoir de façon volontaire et
pacifique après avoir fait ses mandats a
décidé de s'allier avec leur et de
devenir sa tête de pont pour reprendre
le pouvoir à Kinshasa. et il le fait en
appui. C'est c'est presque ça serait
drôle si c'était pas dramatique avec
l'appui de celui qui était le président
de la commission électorale du Congo
Corney Nanga qui par ailleurs avait des
intérêts miniers très importants dans le
sud dans dans le sud-est du Congo au
Katanga et qui a décidé parce queon lui
avait pas donné ce qu'il voulait de
devenir le rebelle et chef de la section
politique du M23 et en fait la section
politique du M23 c'est la couverture des
activités militaires du RA et donc t
tous ces acteurs se sont réunis et avec
l'appui de Paul Kagamé cherchent à
provoquer un coup d'état contre le
président actuel du de la RDC qui
lui-même il y a quelques mois avait subi
un premier une première tentative de
coup d'état dont vous avez peut-être
entendu parler. Il y avait eu des
miliciens États-uniens qui avaient été
arrêtés et un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont été condamnées à mort.
Qui qui s'intéresse à ça ? Qui est-ce
qui docum qui documente les intérêts de
X Y Z ? Est-ce qu'il y a une instance
internationale qui va dans le même sens
que vous ? C'est très important parce
que euh je vais vous donner un exemple.
En fait, ça fait euh des décennies que
c'est un sujet de préoccupation assez
hypocrite. C'est-à-dire qu'on a des ONG
qui dénonce le fait qu'il y a un pillage
un pillage des ressources euh minières
de la RDC et que ces ressources minières
alimentent le conflit. Premier point.
Ensuite, vous avez une réaction
institutionnelle de la part des États
pour dire "Oui, c'est vrai, c'est un
problème, il faut qu'on corrige ça."
L'Union européenne qui adopte des
règlements, les États-Unis aussi qui
adoptent des sanctions et ainsi de
suite, mais qui en réalité euh ne
cherche pas à régler le problème.
C'est-à-dire que en réalité, la seule
chose que ça produit, c'est un marché de
blanchiment des minéraux qui consiste à
cacher leur provenance pour continuer
l'exploitation. De sorte qu'aujourd'hui,
le Rwanda est devenu le principal
producteur de coltant au monde alors que
ils n'ont pas de mine de coltant. Vous
voyez donc la RDC a tenté des actions
par exemple contre Apple en Europe et en
France. Le parquet de Paris a classé
sans suite à ce stade la procédure qui
avait été menée par mon confrère William
Brudon et donc on se retrouve dans une
situation où en fait il y a une sorte
d'inertie qui est construite. Après il y
a une guerre géopolitique majeure sur
cette région. Pourquoi ? parce que vous
imaginez bien que qui maîtrise euh le
point de départ de toute la chaîne de
production technologique euh du monde
d'aujourd'hui maîtrise tout simplement
le monde derrière. Donc en fait, il y a
les Chinois et les États-Unis qui ont
qui jouent un qui sont dans un balai
actuellement actuellement dans la
région. Donc les Chinois en fait avaient
pris beaucoup d'influence au Congo sous
Kabila. Ils avaient réussi à installer
et même quelque partellement à
stabiliser la production de minerais.
euh notamment dans le Katanga et à
quelque part réparé un certain nombre de
de difficultés qui a été généré par les
entreprises précédentes occidentales. En
réalité, très rapidement des abus
similaires ont commencé à s'appliquer.
Il faut savoir que un un une des
nombreuses difficultés que génère tout
cela, c'est tout simplement que c'est
des gamins qui sont envoyés dans les
mines pour aller chercher les minerais
dans des conditions qui sont
parfaitement déplorables.
Un des objectifs primordiaux de Trump,
c'est de reprendre la main sur ces
minerais. Donc il il y a des accords qui
ont été signés récemment et donc voilà,
il y a quelques jours à Washington, il y
a eu un premier accord qui a été signé
entre le Ronda et la RDC sous la tutelle
des États-Unis qui est assez flou et qui
prévoit notamment la possibilité pour
les États-Unis de reprendre la main sur
l'exploitation de minerais mais qui en
fait va perpétuer la situation. Pourquoi
? parce que elle elle cet accord prévoit
notamment que l'oranda puisse développer
des
des usines de traitement des minerais de
minerais qui sont exploités au Congo.
Donc vous voyez deux factaux. En réalité
ce qu'on est en train de légitimer,
c'est une forme d'annexion de l'est de
la RDC par l'Oranda. Ce qui pose une
question très intéressante parce que les
frontières de la RDC, elles ont été
dessinées un soir par le roi des Belges
avec avec ses amis après la conférence
de Berlin et ainsi de suite et elles
n'ont aucune signification h qu'elle
soit ethnique, historique ou ainsi de
suite. Elle est d'ailleurs la
colonisation un rôle très important euh
dans les conséquences qu'il y a eu
quelques décennies plus tard, notamment
avec le génocide. rondait les tensions
identitaires qui continuent à exister.
On pourrait revenir dessous dessus, mais
en quelques mots, il y avait une
coexistence très organisée depuis des
siècles entre les communautés et toutsi
chaque communauté avait une fonction
spécifique et tout cela était organisé
de façon traditionnelle avec toute une
série de rituels et ainsi de suite et
les Belges sont arrivés un peu à la
serppe, on fait n'importe quoi après des
Allemands et ont réussi et ont quelque
part déstabilisé cet équilibre et ont
aussi réifié les communautés. C'estàd
que les communautés ont fini par
considérer qu'elles étaient déterminées
seulement par leur ascendance qu'elle
soit ou tout et c'est pas ou tout pardon
et c'est pareil au Congo avec les
Lendou. Donc on est dans une situation
où on est en train de purger tout ça va
doucement mais la question qui se pose
en réalité c'est celle du maintien de
l'ordre poste 45 et de façon générale
depuis les décolonisations. Est-ce que
ces frontières ont du sens ou pas ? Vous
souvenez que Sarkozi, Nicolas Sarkozy
qui était président de la France avait
mis les pieds dans le plat de façon
particulièrement grossière et vulgaire
en disant bon bah il va falloir
redessiner tout ça ce qui était pas très
opportun mais en réalité ce que fait le
Rwanda de facto revient un peu à ça
c'estàdire annexer une partie du
territoire
d'un d'un état qui n'a que cinq
hélicoptères pour l'ensemble de ces
activités militaires et civiles donc qui
n'a aucune capacité à avoir un contrôle
effectif sur cette partie de son
territoire. On va revenir sur ce sujetl
après. Vous, qu'est-ce qui vous est
arrivé ? Vous êtes partis là-bas, on
s'est vu 3 jours avant ou 2 jours avant,
euh 48 heures plus tard euh vous étiez à
l'Ostau. Donc, je voudrais avoir plus
d'informations, même si on s'est tenu au
courant de votre état de santé par
différents brillens.
Est-ce que vous voulez nous raconter ce
qui vous est arrivé ?
quelques mots, je un peu plus que
quelques mots, je prends le vol à enfin
je prends différents vols qui me font
amener à partir de Bruxelles vers
Kinshasa. Reste justement de des liens
coloniaux qui ont existé entre les deux
pays. Et je commence à avoir de lourdes
difficultés respiratoires et des accès
de fièvre soudain dans l'avion qui
m'ent.
Euh d'équipage me donne ce qu'ils ont,
pas grand-chose de l'blu profane et
compagnie. J'ess des prises de
température pendant le vol. Non,
j'essaie de les calmer. J'essaie de de
modérer la chose en me disant bon, ça
peut être donc difficulté à respirer
mais aussi à à avaler. Euh ce qui était
assez étonnant, c'était des c'était
surtout les variations subites par
rapport à la fièvre très soudaine qui
qui me faisait particulièrement
violence.
Le vol est long, enfin c'est le
Bruxelles Kinshasa. J'arrive à Kinshasa,
j'arrive à marcher. Tu proposé de faire
demi-tour ou pas ? Non, à ce moment-là
parce que j'ai essayé de de j'essayé, je
me disait peut-être que j'ai pris enfin
je sais pas, peut-être qu'il m'arrive
quelque chose. Enfin, c'était et vers la
fin du vol, quand je commence à avoir du
mal à à respirer, là je commence à
m'inquiéter. Mais en même temps, je
commençais à être dans un état second
aussi. C'est un peu
de j'ai pas perdu conscience mais
j'étais enfin je m'endormais donc enfin
j'étais dans des situations un peu
étranges. Je sors de l'avion, j'arrive à
marcher euh je je rentre dans un dans
une voiture et euh et là je fais savoir
que ça va pas du tout et les personnes
qui étaient venues me chercher, des
confrères euh me disent il faut enfin il
faut vous amener à l'hôpital
directement. Donc je vais à l'hôpital
euh euh à l'hôpital qui est sur le
chemin en fait euh entre l'aéroport et
mon hôtel qui a pas été choisi. Euh donc
je découvrirais plus tard que le
propriétaire venait d'être enfermé un
mois avant par les autorités du fait de
son de ses liens un Indien très très
fameux à Kinshasa du fait de ces liens
justement suputés avec avec le Rwanda
dans le cadre du conflit. Il faut savoir
qu' qu'à Kinshasa l'ambiance est très
particulière à ce moment-là.
C'est-à-dire qu'on est dans une
situation Kabila est en train Joseph
Kabila donc l'ancien président est en
train de sortir
euh euh du de sa réserve et commence à à
à le M23 commence à annoncer qu'ils
veulent prendre Mumbashi qui est donc
une grande ville de l'est du Congo qui
est en fait le même chemin qui avait été
pris par le père de Kabila pour arriver
à à Kinshasa et faire tomber Mobutou.
Donc on commence à voir qu'il y a des
risques de coup d'état réel avec une
méfiance très importante sur enfin on
est dans un pays qui est en situation de
guerre effective. Donc j'arrive à
l'hôpital. Euh là, il y a un quiproco
assez important parce que apparemment
les autorités sont très rapidement
informées et pendant toute la période,
je vais être suivi par un agent de
l'ANR, l'Agence nationale de
renseignement euh qui va en fait me
couver euh dans la chambre où je vais
être euh placé avec, c'est pour ça que
je vous racontais ce qui s'est passé
avec l'hôpital, des tensions liées au
fait que le propriétaire a été suspecté
d'être en lien avec leura, que je suis
venu pour enfin bon bref, tout le monde
se regarde en chien de faillance
particulièrement inquiet et moi au
milieu de tout ça en ne comprenant
absolument pas ce qui est en train de
m'arriver tout de suite il y a des
suspicions d'empoisonnement c'est la
première chose qui m'est dit par des par
le médecin qui qui m'est donné qui qui
sont très inquiets qu'il y a
potentiellement par ailleurs une
bactériémie qui est en train de se
développer et donc que ça pourrait être
un ce qu'ils appellent un spa invasif
donc c'estàd une infection bactérienne
avec au streptocoque
qui aurait qui qui serait sur le point
de provoquer un chape sceptique. le
pronostic est est inquiétant et très
étrange. Enfin, c'est qu'il y a il y a
quelque chose qui va pas. Il y a à la
fois une souche virale et une souche
bactérienne. Ça, on le saura un peu plus
tard avec les cultures qui vont être
faites et ainsi de suite. Et donc, on on
on m'hospitalise mais et on commence à
me à me donner un traitement assez
lourd. Mais euh les personnes des
autorités qui sont impliquées, qui sont
je pense sous pression et euh avec qui
ont été prévenus, j'imagine par par mes
confrères et qui sont sous pression je
pense de leur hiérarchie. Il faut pas
qu'il arrive dans une situation comme
celle-ci quelque chose euh de grave ou
qui puisse avoir des conséquences, font
des pieds, des mains pour me sortir de
l'hôpital pour dire "Non, non, il faut
pas qu'il reste." Donc, j'assiste à des
engueulades homériques entre le
personnel médical et et ces
personnes-là. on me sort euh la soirée
euh pour m'amener à après que j'ai reçu
des traitements euh préventifs, que ce
soit des antibiotiques lourds et ainsi
de suite et et qu'on m injecté enfin
qu'on m mis sous perfusion pendant
pendant une heure et qu'on met qu'on
qu'on m qu'on m'est mis notamment un
antidouleur assez puissant et on me sort
de l'hôpital pour me laisser
dans l'hôtel
à je ne dors pas de la nuit et à 6h du
matin, je suis dans un état et on me
ramène d'urgence à l'hôpital et là je
suis pris en charge entièrement et je
vais être hospitalisé pendant une
semaine par le service de médecine
interne qui va essayer après après les
premiers traitements d'urgence qui va
essayer de comprendre ce qui m'est
arrivé et alors les monocultures enfin
je sais pas si c'est monoculture en tout
cas les cultures bactériologiques qui
vont être mises en œuvre vont ne vont
donner qu'une souche inconnue. Moi je
suis en RDC, je sais pas dans quelle
mesure ils sont capables
d'identifier effectivement ce qui s'est
passé et qu'est-ce qui est lié soit à
l'étrangeté de ce qui vient de
m'arriver, soit en effet à un manque de
moyen sur le moment ou une erreur de
traitement. Ce que je sais que c'est que
ça va être une panique pendant pendant
ces quelques jours particulièrement
importante avec une prise en charge des
autorités si importantes que lorsque
j'en sors, je un encadrement militaire.
c'est des gens avec des kalashnikov et
ainsi de suite qui vont qui vont qui qui
vont me sortir de là et et qui vont
m'interroger sur ce qui s'est passé puis
qui vont me permettre de
rencontrer un certain nombre de
personnes pour après m'avoir interrogé
sur ce que je venais faire et ainsi de
suite euh euh me dire queils sont à
pleinement à disposition et et et me
proposer de tout accompagnement
nécessaire pour pour continuer ma
mission. Et euh alors moi j'
déteste surtout la enfin ce que j'ai
appris depuis depuis longtemps parce que
ça fait 10 ans qu'avec Wikileak et ainsi
de suite on fait face à un certain
nombre d'événements qui parfois sont
compliqués, c'est que euh la dernière
des choses à faire, c'est de s'avancer
sur des sujets sur lesquels on n' pas
d'éléments qui permettent de prouver euh
ce qui s'est passé. Moi, je n'ai pas
d'éléments qui permettent de prouver ce
qui m'est arrivé. Ce que je sais, c'est
que euh j'ai fait l'objet d'un
traitement extraordinairement lourd. qui
a aujourd'hui encore des conséquences,
que ça a généré une inquiétude
particulièrement marquée de la part des
autorités, que je n'ai pas eu accès au
résultat justement de ces études
bactériologiques, ainsi de suite qui ne
m'ont jamais été transmis et euh et que
pour être tout à fait honnête, ça m'est
arrivé très rarement, peut-être une ou
deux fois ces dernières années, j'ai eu
peur. J'ai eu peur au sens physique du
terme. peur comme quand vous voyez un un
film d'horreur, vous voyez ? Enfin,
cette sorte de choses qui vous prend
encore et euh et l'une des dernières
fois que ça m'était arrivé, la dernière
fois, je pense que ça m'était arrivé,
c'était quand il y avait des équipes qui
c'était qui avaient été visiblement
placé autour de mon domicile à Paris qui
tournaient autour de mes fenêtres. Il y
avait eu quelques preuves qui avaient
été de révélé par la suite et qui
démontraient qu'il y avait une volonté
de me nuire dont je ne savais pas
quelles seraient les conséquences. Ce
que je sais c'est qu'il y a eu depuis
quelques années un certain nombre
d'opérations, je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on peut les qualifier qui ont
cherché à me viser. J'ai eu de la part
d'une source qui est très installée dans
dans le système sécuritaire français qui
m'a indiqué qu'à la fin 2023 quand je
défendais Ousman Sonco qui était alors
opposant à Macky Sall et que nous étions
attention de pas donner trop d'éléments
pour pas relever votre source. C'est
pour ça que que que je suis pas rentré
dans les détails de cette personne, ce
qui est toujours compliqué parce qu'il
faut essayer de d'étayer ce que l'on
avance et et en même temps de de ne pas
exposer les personnes qui nous
permettent de le savoir.
Je sais qu'il y a eu une une volonté de
la part de certains acteurs d'atteindre
à ma vie à ce moment-là. Vous voyez, ça
c'est j'ai une euh un élément et par
contre ce que je sais aussi et ça je
pense que je peux le dire sans exposer
personne, c'est que la DGE était informé
était informé de ce risque qui me
concerne et je ne sais pas s'il y a eu
d'action de la part des autorités pour
l'empêcher. Ça c'est un élément qui m'a
paraît important de partager. On sait
aussi que j'ai fait l'objet d'une
certain nombre de tentatives de
déstabilisation ces dernières années de
sorte qu'en fait ce que l'on construit à
la fois en terme en terme juridique, en
terme politique et ainsi de suite était
devenu presque secondaire par rapport à
la chronique mondaine de scandales euh
accusations diffamatoires et ainsi de
suite qui ne cessaiit de se répéter pour
essayer de nous distraire de ces falais.
C'est pour ça que c'était pour moi
important d'encadrer cet événement dans
une présentation plus générale de ce qui
est en train de se jouer au Congo et des
enjeux en cours à ce niveau-là. Je vais
vous poser quelques questions pour
essayer d'y voir un peu plus clair.
48 heures avant le départ, est-ce qu'il
y a eu des contacts un peu bizarres ? Il
y en a eu avec en fait il y a eu il y a
eu deux choses. À la sortie de de notre
dernier entretien de de l'entretien
précédent que nous avons fait, j'ai
donné une conférence dans la foulée à la
maison de l'Amérique latine sur les
révolutions politiques en Amérique
latine et sur
le lien et les conséquences que l'on
pourrait en tirer. Et il y a eu des
personnes et en particulier une personne
qui m'avait semblé un peu étrange, qui
sont approché de moi, qui ont cherché à
me donner des enveloppe et ainsi de
suite que ce que je mets toujours de
côté pour des raisons de sécurité. Euh
il y a euh dans ça c'est ça c'est la
difficulté dans une situation comme la
mienne, c'est comment est-ce que vous
faites lorsque vous êtes sans protection
de quel corde que ce soit et que vous
êtes en train de toucher à des enjeux si
fondamentaux. Je vous donne un exemple.
Par exemple, si je reviens par exemple à
ce qu'on est en train de faire, je l'ai
ramené ici pour vous le montrer, sur la
question palestinienne et et euh et et
israélienne à la Cour pénale
internationale. On a je vous présenter
le dernier document qu'on que que j'ai
soumis il y a c'était ce jour sur en
défense de victimes palestiniennes qui
sont à Gaza. Donc vous imaginez le
courage presque fou qu'ils ont eu en
décidant de se constituer à la cour
pénale internationale contre des
dirigeants israéliens Benjamin Netaniaou
et Joam Galant. Et ça donc ça c'est ce
document c'est quoi ? C'est une réponse.
Oui mais c'est c'est très très rèvement
pour pour vous donner une idée.
Quand je vous disais qu'on était que 10
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est que 10 ?
Attendez donc là des gens bizarres vous
ont approché 48 heures avant le départ.
Il y a eu il y a eu de il y a eu deux
moments à ce moment-là et ensuite plus
plus de façon plus proche de
des faits à l'aéroport en transit dans
un des transits que que j'ai eu à
prendre quelqu'un qui s qui est venu et
qui s'est accollé à moi de façon
particulièrement significative
dans la prétention de vouloir me me
saluer, me féliciter, ainsi de suite.
C'est quelque chose que les gens ne font
jamais parce que comme vous imaginez
bien, les gens ont une forme de enfin de
respect, de distance et ils sont un peu
intimidés quand quand ils cherchent à
supposément très grand. Je suis plus
grand que ce que l'on pense apparemment
mais et donc il y a eu des éléments
comme ça ponctuels qui sont en fait les
seuls que je peux que je peux vous
donner et qui encore une fois ne prouve
rien. Ne prouve rien. C'est juste que en
l'état c'est ce que j'ai. À l'arrivée à
l'hôpital à Kinshasa,
est-ce qu'ils ont fait des recherches de
toxique ? Est-ce qu'il vous ont passé
lipider mal à laalou pour savoir s'il y
avait injection, spray, solvant
et est-ce qu'ils ont fait des cultures
pour chercher des toxiques ? Oui, donc
ils ont fait les cultures, ils ont pas
du tout fait de recherche sur sur fait
des cultures. Est-ce qu'ils ont fait des
recherches de toxique ? Ils ont ils ont
fait des cultures qui avaient vocation à
identifier ce qui ce qui ce qui ce qui
m'avait s'il y avait un élément
extérieur qui n'était pas naturel. Prise
de sang, il y a eu prise évidemment.
Est-ce qu'ils vous ont pris un peu de
caca ? Vous vous rendez pas compte ? et
pardonnez-moi, mais que ce soit des des
fesses ou ou des urines, évidemment,
mais tout de suite, enfin, imaginez-vous
la la l'inquiétude qui pouvait naître
chez dans un contexte comme celui-là.
Encore une fois, avec la pression des
autorités qui ont une suspicion à
l'égard des dirigeants de cet hôpital,
la présence la présence sur place de
personnes des en représentant les
autorités immédiatement, c'était une
situation qui était et encore une fois
la sensibilité du sujet que l'on était
en train de toucher mais aussi de ma
personne. Il faut savoir que euh ça
faisait tâche quand même de voilà et à
ces dernières années, j'ai fini quand
même par incarner dans un certain nombre
de pays du fait de mon action en défense
d'un certain nombre d'individus. Là
encore, hier euh je sais pas si vous
avez vu, mais il y a une des personnes
les plus influentes dans l'Afrique
francophone qui s'appelle Nathalie Gamb
euh qui euh euh vient d'être placé sur
la liste de sanctions de l'Union
européenne parce qu'elle a donné une
conférence un jour dans invitée par une
ONG à Berlin avec des députés allemands
qui visiblement auraient des liens avec
Wagner et ainsi de suite. cette personne
là, je la défends comme Kemy Seba, comme
Ousman Sonko, comme un certain nombre de
militants dans dans dans ces territoires
dont je n'ai pas à parler et donc tout
ça va venir, on va mais tout ça générer
une forme de ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que il y a quand quand je me rends
sur ces territoires là, ça cette
présence ne passe pas inaperçue. C'est
ça que je voulais dire. Et du coup, en
fait, ça génère une sorte de
d'inquiétude qui dans un contexte comme
celui-ci à l' se déploie. prise de sang,
prise d'urine, prise de sel, analyse,
perfusion immédiatement. Enfin, bien
sûr, il y avait quoi dans la perfusion ?
Il y avait des antibiotiques croisé euh
euh préventivement et en fait le jour
suivant, ils vont accroître. Je me suis
retrouvé avec avec des des
antibiotiques. Enfin, je veux dire quand
je suis rentré au Portugal et que j'ai
montré la liste des traitements. Oui,
parce que j'étais suivi au Portugal
derrière évidemment, bien sûr. Et et
qu'ils ont vu ce que j'avais ce que
j'avais reçu, ils m'ont dit "Mais enfin
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Ils hallucinaient par rapport ils
suicidaient par rapport au ça mais aussi
par rapport aux résultats qui ne
serait-ce que sur même sur les globules
blancs ainsi de suite continu à être
beaucoup trop élevé par rapport à à la
situation que je connaissais. Donc il y
a un traitement préventif parce qu'ils
ne savent pas ce qui est en train de se
passer. Extraordinairement lourd et
extraordinairement lourd à partir de la
réhpitalisation. La première c'est un
traitement préventif simple avec tout de
suite en effet prise de sang, prise
d'urine, prise de sel. ça sera seulement
le deuxème jour et
et donc oui et et perfusion avec surtout
des antidouleurs parce que j'avais
j'étais dans une situation qui était
particulièrement désagréable. à ce
moment-là, on a vu sur Twitter euh
quelqu'un qui a écrit une note comme
quoi que c'était qu'une simple tourista
ou quelque chose de une tourista
amélioré et que vous étiez traité pour
des verrs intestinaux et et euh et et ça
c'était ça c'était ça c'était
passionnant aussi parce que je l'ai
découvert après coup he sur le moment,
j'avais un peu de mal à suivre mais
c'est tout d'abord une vague de compte
avec très peu de d'activités ou de
personnes qui suivent ainsi de suite qui
prétendent que je n'ai pas été
hospitalisé. Voyez, d'abord la première
vague qui consiste tout de suite à
éteindre l'inquiétude et et surtout à à
essayer d'éviter que queil y ait une
forme de de réaction populaire défensive
qui se mette en place. Premier point.
Deuxième point, quand visiblement pour
une raison ou une autre, j'ai pas suivi
en détail sur le moment comme vous
imaginez, mais il y a des éléments qui
permettent d'établir que je suis
hospitalisé. Là, là, ça devient très
inquiétant et et de ce j'ai essayé de
recouper. Apparemment, il y a un temps
de latence. Il y a il y a il y a quelque
chose de Et tout de suite l'objectif
c'est quoi ? Je pense je pense
honnêtement que ça a été construit,
c'est de s'assurer que s'il m'arrive
quelque chose sérieusement,
ça soit lié à la RDC, ça soit lié au
Congo, ce soit lié à l'Afrique. le
cliché de la tourista et évidemment tout
de suite la vulgarité qui consiste à
rattacher à des diarrées, à des gastros
et ainsi de suite pour
en vous savez vous êes vous êtes dans
une je pense que les personnes en face
de moi se retrouvent dans une situation
où c'est c'est des gens
qui dont le pouvoir repose sur leur
maîtrise du rapport à la communication
et ils ont compris que la communication
c'est de l'affect. Or, un affect positif
qui s'attache sur moi doit immédiatement
être contré par un autre affect. Peux
pas l'être par la rationalité, ça ne
sert à rien. Et donc en fait, s' un
affect d'inquiétude et donc
d'attachement qui se révèle et qui est
inquiétant en ce qu' il révèle qu'on est
beaucoup plus nombreux et beaucoup plus
solidaire que ce qu'ils pensent et ce
qu'ils espèrent. D'accord. Je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable. Je vais je
vais mettre à la place de d'être acteur.
J'ai je vais grossir le trait. Je vais
dire Juan Branco est en train
d'instrumentaliser sa tourista pour
avoir déclencher un dans ses dans ses
troupes. J'étais pas enfin j'ai rien
fait. J'étais j'étais pas j'étais pas
sur les réseaux. Enfin, j'étais j'étais
incapable de faire quoi que ce soit.
Enfin, je je veux bien mais juste quelle
est la quel est le contreaffect ? C'est
le rire. Vous voyez, c'est la dérision,
c'est l'humiliation. Il faut absolument
et et donc et c'est là où on est dans
dans un monde où la l'absence de limite
se révèle assez fort quoi. C'est-à-dire
que vous avez quelqu'un qui est
peut-être en danger de mort, vous en
savez rien objectivement, vous savez
juste qu'il est hospitalisé, ainsi de
suite et vous avez vous avez lancé une
campagne qui va provoquer en fait une
campagne. Donc là, c'était une campagne
qui était à base de la photo que vous
avez publié sur votre compte Twitter
avec avec une avec une table de soin sur
le côté avec C'était bien plus tard.
C'était bien plus tard. Ça en fait ça
faisait des jours qu'ils étaient dans
cette dynamique là. Et en fait moi moi
je poste la photo pour rassurer les
gens. C'estàd que je suis en train de
sortir de la situation. Je pas j'ai on
m'a dit que beaucoup de gens étaient
inquiets. Je reçois des messages de
partout auquels j'ai pas la force de
répondre et ainsi de suite et je me dis
je vais prendre une photo avec l'équipe
soignante pour dire tout va bien vous
inquiétez pas on est en forme et et donc
il y a un moment de sidération de la
part de ce qui enfin des d'adversaires
politiques en réalité. C'est ça ce qui
ce que ça et et donc derrière à un
moment donné il y a quelqu'un qui va
mais je sais pas si c'est très
intéressant en même temps c'est
intéressant qui va essayer de de zoomer
sur l'image et qui va devinant seulement
une partie du traitement dont je fais
l'objet et qui va par ailleurs parce que
ça c'est pas lisible prétendre que c'est
X alors que c'était Y dire oh mais non
mais ça ça doit être un traitement pour
une gastro une touristage je sais pas je
pas ce que c'était exactement des ver
parasites en fait vous savez Moi, moi
mon inquiétude à ce moment-là, c'est
laquelle ? C'est je suis dans une
situation de vulnérabilité particulière
dans une zone de guerre. J'ai quand même
pas mal d'adversaires assez assez
méchants et qui ont des moyens. Donc ma
première priorité c'était de ne rien
communiquer avant d'être en dehors de
cette situation de vulnérabilité. Ça
c'était le premier point d'être prise en
charge, d'être rassuré, ainsi de suite.
Euh et je peux vous dire que
paradoxalement même les autorités
françaises étaient inquiète. C'estd que
quand j'ai échangé avec l'ambassadeur à
Kinshasa sur la situation, il m'a écrit
pour me dire qu'il était soulagé d'avoir
pu parler avec moi parce qu'il ne savait
pas ce qui était en train de se passer,
qu'ils avaient pas réussi à me trouver,
dit-il en tout cas la partie de la
chancellerie et qu' il savait juste
qu'il y avait un ressortissant français
qui était en grande difficulté quelque
part à Kinshasa. Et donc c'est pas un
jeu, vous voyez, c'est pas un jeu parce
que il pour les gens en tout cas sains
qui sont quand même la grande majorité
de la haute fonction publique française
et ainsi de suite, c'est une
responsabilité particulièrement lourde
que quelque chose de cet ordre-là. Donc
qu'il y ait des rigolards sur Twitter
qui soit instrumentalisés, orientés,
payés ou soit même paraître détestation
de soi, de l'autre, qu'importe,
cherchent à à monter une bulle autour et
qui s'excite en fait de ces situations.
Là, pour reprendre une expression
américaine, il y a des il y a des
adultes dans la salle. D'accord. Moi,
mes enjeux ne sont pas que mes enjeux.
ce qui m'arrive à moi peut toucher par
ricochet à beaucoup de personnes et j'ai
noté d'ailleurs l'inquiétude qui est née
et et à travers le nombre de messages
qui qui ont été reçus du sérieux de ce
qu'on est en train de construire de
façon générale et je pense que c'est un
signal qui a été envoyé aussi à nos
adversaires. Donc il y a un moment donné
il faut aussi prendre un peu de distance
par rapport à à ces choses-là et dire
qu'il y a des gens qui s'amusent et qui
pensent que c'est décent et qui pensent
que ça a un sens de jouer à ce petit
jeu-là. C'est une chose. Nous
entre-temps, on joue avec notre vie et
potentiellement on affecte les vies de
beaucoup d'autres personnes. Donc un peu
de distance. Question technique euh le
consul de France s'est rapproché de vous
au bout de combien de temps ? Non non,
c'est moi qui l' qui qui lui écrit.
C'est moi qui ai fini par lui écrire au
bout de au bout de en sortant de
l'hospitalisation quand j'étais un peu
en capacité pour le rassurer. Et il m'a
tout de suite répondu très Est-ce que
les espagnols et les Portugais ont été
un peu cru tout de suite espagnol mais
tout de suite mais bien sûr mais comme
au Sénégal c'est là c'est la deuxième
fois où ça arrive alors il y a il y a
vous êtes franco-espagnol
franco-espagnol et et d'origine
portugaise et et de et et
honnêtement l'appareil diplomatique
espagnol n'est pas aussi efficace en
théorie que le français et n'est pas
aussi développé que le français n'a pas
la même expérience que le français.
Je veux pas mettre en gêne ou en
difficulté l'appareil diplomatique
français. Je suis dans une position
d'opposition radicale au pouvoir en
place et l'appareil diplomatique
français est nécessairement pris en
tenaille entre la nécessaire défense
évidemment de ces sujets de ces citoyens
et le respect des des instructions
prérogatives qui leur sont accordées par
le pouvoir en place et notamment par le
président de la République.
de façon structurelle, je cherche à ne
pas les mettre dans l'embarras et
surtout lorsque je me retrouve dans des
situations comme au Sénégal où j'étais
en opposition frontale avec la position
adoptée par la France dans ce territoire
en défense de quelqu'un qui en subissait
les conséquences. Il m'a paraissait
naturel de ne pas aller les solliciter,
de ne pas me mettre à la moindre
difficulté en position d'aller kemander
et ainsi de suite. Et donc je n'ai je
n'ai aucune difficulté de principe quant
au fait qu'il y a une forme de distance
mutuelle. et que seulement et que et
d'où le geste que j'ai fait lorsque j'ai
compris que j'étais tiré d'affaires, que
les autorités locales me prenaient en
charge, me protégeait, avait développé
des des militaires enfin déployer des
militaires afin afin de afin de me
suivre qui consistait à envoyer un
message à l'ambassadeur dont j'imaginais
qu'il n'était ce n'était pas une
position très agréable pour lui.
J'imagine qu'en réalité, il avait été
parfaitement informé d'où j'étais et
avait informé en retour de la sorte mais
lui dire vous inquiétez pas a priori
c'est bon, il va pas y avoir des
difficultés particulières. Et l'autre
élément, c'est que par ailleurs,
typiquement l'ambassadeur, je l'ai
rencontré à l'Élysée en 2010 quand
j'étais euh petit assistant du procureur
de la Cour pénale nationale justement
sur les questions africaines, juste
parce qu'il était auprès du conseiller
Afrique de l'Élysée dans les beaux
bureaux du du de rue de l'Élysée.
J'avais gardé un un souvenir de cette
personne avec qui j'aurais probablement
à travailler demain si on se retrouve en
position d'exercer des fonctions
importantes en France. Donc il y a un
moment donné, voyez la il faut savoir
qui est l'adversaire et qui est
l'ennemi. Il faut il faut se retrouver
dans une situation, il faut accepter le
fait qu'il y a des méthodes parfois sale
qui soient mis en œuvre pour vous
déstabiliser. Il y a une des une des
théories, c'est que ça a été un farce et
attrape. Vous voyez que ça a été une
façon d'ffrayer, une façon d'envoyer un
signal, une façon de dire fais attention
où tu mets les pieds et ainsi de suite.
C'est des enjeux fondamentaux. Vous
voyez, il faut le farc attrape de qui ?
Parce que je vois mal les Français faire
ça
peut-être pour vous. Il faut il faut
avoir à l'esprit que pour contourner le
républicanisme
de nos services de renseignement, pour
contourner le républicanisme de nos
forces de police,
l'affaire Benala avait révélé que son
recrutement et celui de Ludovic Shaker
avait notamment pour vocation d'utiliser
leur fonction de réservice de la
gendarmerie et de la police pour
constituer un groupe de sécurité à
l'Élysée qui a amené notamment à la
dérive du 1er mai et donc au fait que
Alexandre Benala soit pris sur le fait
en train de tabasser un manifestant en
ayant des enseignes de police. Cet
élément et dont n'a pas été traité par
les médias comme il aurait dû. Ce qu'il
révélait c'est qu'on essayait de
constituer une forme de garde
prétorienne à l'Élysée avec des
hiérarchies suputé supposé parallèle.
C'est très important de l'avoir à
l'esprit parce que en réalité l'Élysée,
le président de la République ou ses
conseillers ne peuvent pas en dehors des
liens d'amicaux informellement et cetera
donner des instructions directes à des
policiers, à des gendar la on sa on
s'écarte du sujet, il y a rien pour
étayer ça. On va revenir juste si je
pourrais vous dire il y avait un Non non
si ça été étayé médiatiquement mais sauf
que c'est passé inaperçu. Alexandre
Benala Alexandre Benala était chargé de
la réforme des services de sécurité de
l'Élysée et il était censé les
constituer notamment à partir de
personnes qui appartenaient à la
réserve. Vous retrouverez l'article,
vous tapez, c'est vraiment là vous
parlez de quelque chose qui était qui
est sorti en 2018 donc j'ai pas la
source précise mais c'est vraiment pour
c'est pas une information que j'invente
c'est documenté. publé dans je sais pas
si je pas vous dire une bêtise entre le
monde la lettre aou quoi que ce soit
mais c'est un média très informé qui
avait permis d'établir que au moment où
il doit se faire exfiltrer, il y a cet
élément sachez qu'aujourd'hui avec
Benala c'est important par exemple il
est encore aujourd'hui protégé par
l'Élysée Marc Anveld a révélé tout
récemment que l'Élysée a fait sauter un
une notice rouge Interpol qui le visait
du fait de ses liens avec un oligarque
qui lui avait permis de bénéficier d'un
contrat de plus de 3 millions d'euros
sans aucune substance, c'està-dire sans
aucune conséquence. Dernièrement là, il
y a quelques ce qui fait il y a une
procédure qui est-ce qui était ça ?
C'était l'Azerbaïdjan qui avait donc
l'Azerbaïdjan a a lancé un mandat
d'arrêt international enfin une demande
de d'extradition de monsieur Benala
parce qu'il y a des poursuites
judiciaires qui étaient mises envre.
Interpol avait émis une notice rouge et
selon Marcandeveld, l'Élysée est
intervenu pour faire retirer cette
notice rouge, ce qui apparemment est le
cas aujourd'hui, c'est que cette notice
rouge a été retirée. Donc comment est-ce
que quelqu'un qui entre-temps a été
condamné pénalement définitivement pour
ses faits pour d'autres faits les
passeports diplomatiques et ainsi de
suite le coffre on l' retrouvé qu'est-ce
qui fait le la procédure concernant le
coffre a fait l'objet d'un non lieu avec
notamment Pascal Perez qui était la
personne qui l'avait accueilli qui a des
liens
pour le moins proche avec un
avec le milieu du sud. Oui, bien sûr,
parce que euh la personne a été jugée en
assise
euh euh dans mon souvenir à Harl ou à ex
à vérifier à c je pense à la cour
d'assise d'ex et cette et c'est cette
personne qui a accueilli Benala au
moment où il était en fuite en réalité
et qui aurait contribué à faire
disparaître le coffre dans lequel de
l'Élysée enfin que Benala avait à
l'Élysée. Cette personne est encore
aujourd'hui protégée église. Pas par
l'église. C'est ça que je j'ouvre une
parenthèse. Revenons à votre
hospitalisation. Est-ce qu'il y avait un
français ou un espagnol
ou ou quelqu'un de Kinshasa qui gardait
votre porte H24 ? Un agent des services
de renseignement de Kinshasa bien sûr de
de Il s'est présenté à vous. Oui. Alors
ça a été un peu le contact a mis un peu
de temps à à être établi. Il y avait il
y avait quelqu'un qui était à mes pieds.
Moi, vous imaginez bien, les premiers
jours, je n'étais pas véritablement en
état d'échanger. Et et ensuite, c'est
lui qui m'a qui m'a qui m'a qui m'a en
fait. Donc, c'est lui qui le soir même
m'amène
de me sort de l'hôpital pour amener la
chambre d'hôtel. Euh quand on me ramène,
il est installé là avec un autre qui qui
passait régulièrement et ensuite c'est
eux qui vont prendre en charge jusqu'à
la fin du séjour à un niveau justement
pour le coup là beaucoup plus élevé avec
des rencontres et des autorités pour un
peu débriefer ce qui s'est passé et
comprendre ce que je faisais là. Ce
débriefing, quelle question ils vous ont
posé ? Bon là, ça a été euh ça a été la
totale. Vous imaginez bien, enfin, vous
imaginez qu'un état en guerre dans une
situation comme celle-ci euh cherche à
comprendre euh qui peut être l'auteur,
d'où ça peut venir et ainsi de suite et
mène sa procédure pour euh pour avancer
dans cette dans cette direction. Donc ça
a été de très longs échanges avec
beaucoup d'interlocuteurs dans plusieurs
lieux différents. Je pense que j'ai
croisé d'ailleurs un un un agent
français probablement de laAD DGSE dans
une sorte de croisement dans un des
bâtiments officiels qui parce que
c'était pas révélé cette couverture. Bah
c'était clairement un bâtiment des
services de renseignement. Euh c'était
un français qui en sortait et c'est un
français qui m'a regardé avec des yeux
mais que il aurait il pouvait être sous
stupéfiant quoi, tellement ses yeux
étaient euh étaient enfin tellement ses
yeux exprimaient une forme de trouble à
l'égard de me voir euh dans cet
endroit-là. Donc il y a eu cette prise
en charge et ensuite vraiment
enfin je sais pas si si s'ils m'ont
sauvé la vie ou pas, mais ce que je je
peux vous dire c'est que j'ai été pris
en charge de façon exceptionnelle, ce
qui est peut-être surprenant pour les
personnes qui se font des des
préconceptions à l'égard de ces espaces
là. J'ai été protégé. J'ai été protégé
alors que rien euh ne leur imposait de
le faire. Et et et j'ai été très
impressionné par le sérieux avec lequel
ils ont traité de la situation. et pour
s'assurer qu'il y aurait pas de les
questions qui vous sont posées, c'était
quoi ? Mais c'était en fait c'est des
débriefs hein. Vous je pense que vous
êtes vous êtes au courant. C'est très
naïf. Ça commence par quand est-ce que
vous êtes arrivé ? Qu'est-ce que vous
faites là ? Pourquoi vous êtes venu ?
Quel vol vous avez pris ? B voyez, c'est
ça ça va dans tous les sens. C'est c'est
on vous fait danser pour essayer
d'identifier si vous avez une forme de
sincérité, si vous avez une légende.
Donc si vous êtes en train de ce qui est
aussi toujours la question, si vous êtes
là euh pour aider des victimes et ainsi
de suite, euh l'État en face euh
s'interroge pour s'assurer que ce soit
sincère, vrai et ainsi de suite. Donc on
se retrouve dans une situation où euh où
ça a duré le temps qu'il fallait. Je
pense c'était pas trop lourd. ils ont
pris en considération le fait que
j'étais quand même très fatigué et ainsi
de suite. Et en réalité, ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que ça a généré une
forme de lien et et très rapidement, je
me suis retrouvé
présenté à des personnes qui travaillant
elles-mêmes sur ce conflit, que ce soit
justement au sein de d'un certain nombre
d'institutions que je vais pas exposer
tout de suite, euh m'ont demandé dans
quelle mesure je serai en mesure
d'appuyer leurs efforts pour essayer de
régler la situation, participer euh à un
certain nombre d'initiatives qui avaient
qui avaient cours. Je dois admettre
aussi qu'il y avait pas dans donc
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'il y a eu ce
silence pendant mais aussi après tout
d'un coup donc la nité de se protéger.
Vous savez, j'avais connu une situation
un peu similaire quand j'étais allé
enquêter au Centrafrique sur Areva sur
la question de la d'une mine d'uranium
qui avait été rachetée dans la feramine.
Arriva avait dépensé plus de 4 milliards
d'euros pour des mines qui étaient
vides. Euh et donc moi, j'avais décidé
d'aller sur le terrain au nord du
Centrafrique
donc en en moto et compagnie pour pour
me retrouver dans le village concerné.
avait donné une enquête dans le monde
diplomatique, mais euh je n'avais osé le
faire qu'une enfin ça faisait plusieurs
années que je travaillais sur le sujet,
mais je n'ai osé le faire qu'une fois
que le fait que je travaillais pour
Wikileak à l'époque comme conseiller
juridique avait été révélé. Pourquoi ?
parce que dans l'étape préalable qui
sait que mon travail auprès de Juliane
n'était pas Julian Assange n'était pas
public,
les risques qu'il y ait une
instrumentalisation et qu'un accident
arrive entre Bangi et le village où je
devais aller dans des conditions de
sécurité quasi nules était très
important. Voyez, un accident opportun
peut intervenir. Donc à chaque fois,
vous êtes obligé de composer sur ce que
vous dites, ce que vous dites pas, à
quelle mesure et par contre dès le
moment qu'il était rendu public que que
j'étais conseiller juridique puis avocat
de Wikilex, au contraire, ça devenait
très coûteux de me faire avoir un
accident suspicieux en plein milieu de
nulle part au Centrafrique. Vous voyez ?
De me faire disparaître au Centrafrique.
Donc c'est plus dangereux dangereux
d'être un martyre.
Non, il faut pas il y a en fait il faut
il faut mesurer je en fait il faut se
mettre à la place de l'adversaire et du
coup de ce qui serait enfin déjà
d'essayer de mesurer de ce qui serait
prêt à faire donc dans quelle mesure ça
vaut la peine ou pas. C'est pour ça que
j'ai j'ai pris à tâche avec
l'ambassadeur parce que je sais très
bien que le coûp serait aurait été
beaucoup trop important s'il m' arrivait
effectivement quelque chose sur place et
que il n'avait pas d'intérêt en tout cas
une fois que j'étais suffisamment
protégé à ce qu'il se passe quelque
chose. Et par contre, par exemple, quand
j'étais au Kivou en 2012 en pleine
guerria, enfin entre les lignes de
fronte de la guer où plus dangereux en
2013 au Centrafrique
quand en pleine guerre civile en
décembre 2013 avec
pour le coup des tirs à bal réel dans
les rues de Bangi qu'on avait subi avec
un certain nombre de camarades
journalistes alors que j'étais pour ma
thèse et comme et comme reporteur là, je
savais savait que le risque qu'il
m'arrive quelque chose était très
important parce que d'ailleurs quelques
mois plus tard une consœur, une
journaliste française s'est faite tué
à Bangi probablement d'ailleurs par des
personnes affiliées à Wagner dans mon
souvenir. Donc il y avait la possibilité
de se faire tuer est très importante si
vous êtes simple journaliste. un peu
moins dans ce genre de conflit si vous
êtes européen parce que c'est un coût
très important pour les acteurs locaux
mais si vous êtes ciblé par une force
internationale dans l'occurrence si
c'était celle-ci à nouveau ça devient
plus donc il faut en fait vous êtes
toujours en train d'essayer de calculer
pour savoir ce que ce que vous pouvez ou
pouvez pas faire. Quand je me suis rendu
à Haïti l'année dernière, euh j'ai
compris que c'était une erreur. Je me
suis rendu à Haïti euh on on avait
parlé, je vais pas je vais pas vous le
raconter à nouveau, mais à la diaspora
et que je me retrouve dans une situation
où clairement il y avait une tentative
de me de me piéger euh où on me demande
euh de les aider enfin d'aider un acteur
politique local puissant qui venait de
sortir de prison aux États-Unis où il
avait été condamné pour narcotrafic.
C'est un peu étrange. Il est renvoyé là
en pleine crise haïtienne avec une
guerre de gang pas possible et qu'il me
demande si je peux enfin c'est ces
hommes de main me demandent si je peux
les aider à les mettre en contact avec
les Russes pour faire un accord où il
les aide à faire un coup d'état en
échange de quoi ils enverraient les
membres de gang sur le front
russoau-rainien.
C'est vous comprenez qu'il y a il y a il
y a une manipe. Vous voyez qu'en fait ce
qu'on est où ils sont fait une légende
sur vous.
Oui. Alors, soit on est face à des gens
qui ne comprennent rien comment
fonctionne le monde et qui sont dans
leur délire, soit on est sur quelqu'un
qui se fait comme par hasard exfiltré au
bon moment de sa prison américaine, là
où il était condamné pour bien plus de
temps et qu' un moment va servir d'idiot
utiles, soit va être poussé, soit va
clairement en fait travailler pour eux
dans le but de faire tomber quelqu'un ou
plusieurs personnes dans le piège. Et
revenons à Kinshasa une petite seconde.
Donc vous demandez l'autorisation à
votre médecin pour pouvoir sortir. Vous
sortez, vous restez combien de temps sur
place et vous arrivez ensuite dans quel
hôpital en Europe ? Alors je vais pas
vous donner les détails de mon trajet
derrière ni du temps que j'ai resté
encore une fois pour des questions de de
sécurité pour pas exposer les personnes
qui qui avec qui j'ai été mais en
réalité nous on est au courant on peut
pas le dire. Voilà donc ça ça a duré un
certain temps. Quand je suis arrivé au
en Europe par mesure de précaution je me
suis pas fait hospitaliser en France.
euh j'ai préféré et euh et donc euh j'ai
utilisé une de mes bases arrières qui
bon dont je vous ai que exposé euh euh
la situation géographique tout à l'heure
pour euh pour euh pour me mettre au vert
entre guillemets, c'est comme ça qu'on
le dit et pour essayer de de retrouver
aussi parce que non seulement il y a un
épuisement très fort, une tension
extraordinaire, une inquiétude très
forte pour mon entourage et derrière il
y a aussi du temps perdu parce que on on
est on est des unités très légèrement
armées. C'estd que moi l'engagement que
j'ai sur ces causes là fait qu'en retour
on n pas le temps ou ou l'envie de faire
beaucoup d'argent et qui dit pas le
temps ou l'envie de faire beaucoup
d'argent fait très peu de personnes
autour de soi pour assurer le suivi et
ainsi de suite et donc fait que sur des
situations très sensibles comme celle de
la Palestine à la CPI du retard du
retard et il faut prendre prendre
prendre enfin faut tout simplement
continuer à accompagner des personnes.
Là, je suis l'avocat par exemple d'un
des d'un des hackerss qui s'est présumé
hackur qui s'est fait arrêter dans
l'opération contre Shiny Hunters qui est
dirigée par le FBI en France, un des
quatre français qui sont fait arrêter
par miracle. C'est pas arrivé dans cette
phase là, mais c'est des c'est des
situations où tout d'un coup, vous êtes
complètement pris et et tout le reste
reste bloqué. Donc, imaginez-vous une
situation comme celle-ci et le temps que
ça durait. Mais j'aimerais parler
d'ailleurs de cette affaire, mais est-ce
que est-ce que Allez-y, allez-y. Merci.
Donc, dans votre base arrière, les TBIB,
ils vous ont exceptionné. Vous avez
globul blanc au plafond, ils vous ont
fait une batterie de de test. Est-ce
qu'on a revu les français se pointer
pour prendre de vos nouvelles ou est-ce
que le service les services de
renseignement locaux sont venus vous
voir ? Non, moi je pense que dès le
moment que que je préviens que j'essayie
cet échange que qui est une façon
d'envoyer un signal aux autorités
françaises, leur dire ça va, il y a pas
de souci, je vais pas je vais pas faire
de scandale. Enfin et puis par ailleurs
il y a il y a pas de raison de leur
part. Enfin, ils ont d'autres chat à
fouetter, vous voyez. Enfin, c'est quand
même que ce soit l'ambassadeur au Congo
et ainsi de suite. Faut pas non plus euh
l'appareil d'État, c'est pourquoi est-ce
que je vous parlais de Benala Chacur et
compagnie, l'appareil d'État encore une
fois français est largement républicain.
Il faut pas rentrer dans une paranoïa à
l'époque à l'égard de nos propres
services. Je suis en train de prendre
des questions pour savoir si mes impôts
sont bien employés. C'està dire que si
on prend quand même un peu des nouvelles
de nos ressortissants à l'étranger quand
il y a une suspicion à gauche à droite
de truc louche,
je pense que si j'avais demandé si
j'avais eu la naïveté de demander un
rapatriement euh il aurait été organisé.
Vous aviez souscrit mondial assistance
ou Europe Assistance ? Non. Probablement
vous ayez vous aviez payé avec votre
carte bleue, c'est ça ? Ouais. Donc Oui.
Oui. Vous êtes revenu en France il y a
combien de temps ? Euh je vais pas vous
donner de dates précises, mais il y a il
y a il y a il y a quelques jours euh
avec euh donc l'idée de enfin d'essayer
de purger un certain nombre de
difficultés qui étaient nées entre-temps
et euh et d'avancer sur euh sur euh sur
des dossiers dont celui dont dont je
viens de vous parler euh avec ce gamin
de 22 ans autiste euh autiste sévère he
qui mange le même plat depuis 15 ans
tous les jours qui s'est retrouvé qui a
fait l'objet d'une tentative
d'enlèvement il y a il y a 10 jours
parce que vous savez il y a une
multiplication des tentatives
d'enlèvement engagement en France lié
aux cryptomonnaaies à cause d'une
régulation européenne qui fait qu'il est
devenu extraordinairement facile
d'identifier qui est le détenteur de
cryptomonnaie et donc c'est un appel
d'air immense de la part des des réseaux
mafieux criminels et qui alors qu'il est
en train de se remettre de cette
tentative d'enlèvement qui a été
médiatisé he il y a cinq personnes en
détention provisoire je veux dire
quelque chose de très sérieux ses
parents et ainsi de suite qui vivaient
encore dans un Airbnb se fait coffrer
par lui m'a dit 40 rentas de la BRI à
vérifier he enfin en tout cas par par
une lourde équipée en Normandie, le font
venir en France et le place en garde à
vue pendant 96 he où il peut pas se
nourrir parce que il ne mange que des
pattes et apparemment c'est impossible
d'amener des pattes en garde à vue
aujourd'hui parce que les mesures de
sécurité, imaginez-vous qu'il lui arrive
quelque chose. Oui, mais mes coco mais
ça fait 96 he qu'il mange pas donc enfin
il risque de lui arriver sérieusement
quelque chose et on décide d'envoyer ce
gamin en détention provisoire.
Pourquoi ? parce que le FBI et LVMH
l'ont demandé parce que il serait l'un
des petits génies qui arrivait à trouver
des exploit et des zero days, donc des
failles informatiques qui permettaient
d'avoir accès à aux plus grandes
au aux données des plus grandes
entreprises mondiales mais aussi des des
plus grandes institutions
internationales. Et alors là, la France
a cette chose magnifique. En fait, je
parle de ça aussi pour répondre à cette
question sur l'utilisation des impôts.
C'est on a un génie de 22 ans qui qui
est vraiment extraordinaire, qui est pas
du tout apte à la détention. Premier
point, qui
n'est pas du tout quelqu'un qui fait ce
qu'il fait par rappin ou quoi que ce
soit. C'estàd que il est capable de
rentrer dans tous les systèmes
informationnels du monde. Il vit sur une
chaise, si vous voyez l'état de sa
chaise et dans sa chambre vraiment comme
dans un HLM dans des conditions de vie
parfaitement anomique. Euh il il fait
rien de ce qu'il en tire s'il en tire
quelque chose. Et au lieu de le recruter
euh on l'envoie en détention provisoire.
On l'envoie en détention provisoire et
vous assistez à toutes les à toutes les
séquences de la procédure judiciaire
au PJ donc officier de police
judiciaire, procureur et et juge
d'instruction, juge des libertés et
détention un gamin qui n'a pas mangé
depuis 5 jours au moment où où il est
présenté en débat à 22h30 pour savoir
l'audience commence pour savoir s'il
doit aller en détention provisoire ou si
un contrôle judiciaire pourrait suffire
avec un encadrement et puis je sais pas
une petite prise de contact en off de la
part de la DG ou de la DGSE pour dire
est-ce que tu veux pas travailler avec
nous ? un gamin qui a gagné un concours
de la DGSE il y a quelques années comme
ça en passant vraiment euh et qui juste
n'a pas pris le relais pour une raison
très enfin n'a pas continué pour une
raison très simple euh il avait il avait
peur de travailler dans un bureau. Il
avait peur de se pas parce qu'il est
littéralement diagnostiqué d'un trouble
neuropsychique mais à qui en fait en lui
tendant une petite main en luiant un
petit truc sur mesure pour aider l'État
français à faire des merveilles et à se
défendre de façon extraordinaire à
l'égard des puissances étrangères ainsi
de suite ou être offensif. Bah non. Oui.
B alors ça on préférait pas mais mais
faut pas le dire. On l'envoie on
l'envoie au centre pénitentiaire.
J'allais dire lequel mais je pense qu'il
vaut mieux pas. C'est dans une situation
même pas à l'isolement. Alors évidemment
tout le monde non mais il va être à
l'isolement on va lui faire des pattes.
Je sais pas quoi le procureur qui ouais
bon ils seront capables de lui faire des
pâtes à au centre pénitentiaire. Bah non
enfin 2 jours plus tard il a toujours
pas mangé. Ça fait 7 jours qu'il a
toujours pas mangé parce qu'il ne peut
pas pas il le mettent avec un homme de
55 ans dont je n'imagine même pas le
pédigré. J'ai pas envie de savoir ce qui
lui arrivait. Il va se faire repérer euh
dans les 3 jours par toute la smala qui
est sur place et qui va vouloir lui
mettre le grappin dessus et on risque
d'en faire en fait un instrument au
service des plus grands criminels de ce
pays euh avec par ailleurs le choc
carcéral, avec le traumatisme que ça
implique, avec la vulnérabilité dans
laquelle il était et tout le monde
trouve ça normal. Il risque de se
radicaliser peut-être en sortant et de
vouloir se venger. Et pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça ? Pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça ? parce que le FBI
nous a dit que et tout le monde est
super content au point où la juge
d'instruction a en anglais son
instructing judge parce que c'est classe
dans sa signature des mails et et que
les parcetiers ont envie de de faire des
séjours à Washington et de boire des
cocktails avec et de dire "Ah c'est
cool" et d'avoir la petite insigne FBI
et parce que LVMH est partie civile et
que on rigole pas avec LVMH. la
suputation sur Ah oui, c'est en fait
c'est une sorte de tentative d'analyse
sociologique de comprendre pourquoi
est-ce qu'on prend une décision aussi
stupide et et aussi contreproductive
pour le gamin, pour la société française
et pour l'État. Enfin, je veux dire, on
est sur quelque chose qui comment
fabriquer un criminel en quatre étapes.
Encore une fois, vous me diriez il il
faisait des vols de données qu'il
revendait. il avait des Lamborghini, je
sais pas quoi. Non, moi je peux
comprendre que symboliquement c'est pas
possible de le gamin sa chaise, je peux
vous dire c'est enfin je mettrai pas un
pied dessus quoi. Ça fait 15 ans qu'il
refuse qu'on la touche. Elle est
complètement trouée de partout et il vit
avec des pas de panzani. Enfin enfin
c'est c'est et par ailleurs, vous le
voyez, il est complètement inoffensif.
Donc donc est-ce que nos est-ce que nos
impôts sont bien dépensés et est-ce que
notre état fonctionne et tourne bien ?
Je pense que de toute façon vous ayez
pas besoin de cet exemple pour supputer
que mon avis sur le sujet n'est pas
n'est pas très favorable et que celui de
la des Français en général ne l'est pas
non plus. Mon cas encore une fois mon
cas il est en dehors. Quelle que soi les
responsabilités ou non qui peuvent être
attribué à qui que ce soit. Moi, je me
tiens à l'extérieur de ce rapport avec
l'État parce que je vais pas tenir le
discours révolutionnaire le jour et la
nuit allermander
suivez-moi, je suis un Kinshasa. En
fait, c'est pas rigolo d'être dans la
situation à laquelle je suis, qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez faire pour m'aider ? Ça
c'est c'est là où encore à nouveau être
adulte, assumer les responsabilités de
ce qu'on fait, les risques que l'on
prend, ne pas faire peser, ne pas faire
peser sur l'État et sur la société
française les conséquences de ces
démarches que l'on mette en œuvre.
J'avais pas demandé l'assistance
consulaire quand j'ai été arrêté au
Sénégal. Ils sont pas venus me la donner
de même. Ils ont pas ils ont clairement
pas voulu y aller. Voilà, vous voyez, il
y a une sorte de c'est c'est l'ambigué.
C'est je suis je reste français, je
enfin je me bats pour la France, mais je
me bats contre une partie de l'État
français. C'est responsable politique
actuel. Donc, j'essaie de le faire de la
façon la plus juste et éthique possible.
Vous avez des séquelles ? Ah bah là, ça
a été j'ai dû me préparer pour cet
entretien au sens physique du terme.
C'està-dire que parce que la la fatigue,
elle est elle est elle est encore très
présente et on tourne au ralenti. On
tourne au ralenti dans des conditions où
pourtant on est euh je dis on parce que
il y a des gens qui m'ont appuyé. J'ai
une équipe, j'ai j'ai des une assistante
que vous avez croisé. enfin des
personnes qui ont qui ont été
fondamentales pour pour m'aider à à
tenir à à s'assurer que ça ne parte pas
en vrille. Mais mais en réalité c'est un
peu c'est un peu comme les diversions,
les accusations diverses dont je peux
faire l'objet ou ainsi de suite. En
fait, c'est très utile aussi pour nous
faire perdre du temps par rapport aux
causes qu'on défend. Quel type de séquel
physique ? Bah, c'est des fatigues
immenses, des taux euh enfin, je vais
pas vous je vais pas vous donner de
détail, mais enfin, il y a il y a des il
y a il y a des euh il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent pas encore. Enfin, vous
voyez, il y a qui fonctionne pas comme
elle devrait. Et donc, on voilà,
j'attends de de de d'essayer de
enfin voilà que ça se remette
complètement en fonctionnement et ça va
ça va aller. Ça va mieux que il y a il y
a de semaines, ça va mieux qu'il y a un
mois. Enfin voilà, il y a une
construction progressive qui qui est en
construction progressive qui se met en
place et il y a beaucoup à faire parce
que au-delà de l'action juridique dont
on parlait, il y a quand même un projet
politique qu'on est en train de de
construire et de mettre en place qui qui
est très important. Mais est-ce que ça a
changé votre rapport à la la sécurité,
votre propre sécurité ? C'est pas la
C'est en fait on est loin d'être sur le
premier incident euh euh auquel j'étais
confronté ces dernières années. Au
contraire, en fait, moi j'ai euh vous
savez, à mesure que la médiatisation et
ma notoriété ont cru, euh j'ai pu
relâcher les contraintes de sécurité que
j'avais initialement à l'époque de
Wikileaks. Euh j'avais pas de téléphone
portable, euh j'utilisais Tails et euh
et sur un sur un ordinateur. Donc c'està
dire c'est un système d'exploitation
spécifique qui euh efface sauf si vous
mettez une persistance hyper chiffrée
qui efface tout ce que vous faites tous
les jours avec des protocoles de
communication XMPP ainsi de suite. Bon,
des équivalents aujourd'hui plus
accessibles comme signal, mais on était
dans une forme de de de paranoïa absolu
qui s'est relâché paradoxalement à
partir où j'ai rendu public mon
engagement à leur côté. Puis après que
peu un peu mon personnage public c'est
c'est c'est construit. J'ai pas les
moyens de me protéger. C'est pas c'est
pas un c'est pas ça c'est c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut que les gens aient
conscience de notre vulnérabilité et du
fait que l'on est moins vulnérable que
parce qu'il s'engage à nos côtés que
parce qu'il montrent que l'on compte
pour eux. Et c'est pour ça que c'est
important cette contreoffensive sur les
réseaux sociaux. C'est très important
parce que l'objectif c'est de vous
fragiliser et de vous exposer. C'est de
montrer qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
limite quant au fait vous faire du mal
et que ce serait jouable. Et si euh s'il
faut en passer par des mensonges en
disant il y a eu qu'une tourista et
ainsi de suite des choses comme ça euh
bah on le met en œuvre.
Encore une fois, l'autre objectif, je
pense, de cette campagne de propagande,
c'était de s'assurer que ça soit pas
rattachable à la France, que que le
point de départ ne soit pas en France,
mais il soit c'est pour ça en fait parce
queils ont parlé quand ils parlent de
tourista et ainsi de suite, l'objectif
c'est de vous rattacher une maladie
tropicale exotique sur le terrain et et
évidemment c'est de se dire s'il lui
arrive quelque chose, c'était là-bas.
Voyez, nous on a rien à voir avec tout
ça. C'est pour c'est là où je pense
qu'il y a eu calcul que ça a été
construit aussi quand vous regardez les
délais c'était il y a une sorte de comme
un temps de latence le temps de se dire
bon qu'est-ce que et moi j'ai pas voulu
réagir parce que c'est un c'est un en
fait c'est un non sujet en fait c'est
pas ça qui compte ce qui compte c'est ce
qu'on fait effectivement c'est voilà il
y a des incidents, il y a des
difficultés il faut il faut il faut faut
il faut danser il faut savoir il faut
savoir danser avec avec le avec le le
monde. Donc euh pour résumer
trivialement, vous êtes turbulent et
vous empoisonnez la vie de beaucoup de
gens. Euh ils vous ont cherché vous
empoisonner. Ils vous ont peut-être ils
ont peut-être chercher à vous rendre là
pareil. Euh pour vous euh quels sont les
trois pôles, trois personnes, trois pays
qui vous en veulent le plus ? Pourquoi
est-ce que je vous parlais de la
Palestine tout à l'heure ? Pourquoi
est-ce qu'on est que 10 avocats dans le
monde entier à représenter des victimes
palestiniennes ?
Le Guardian a révélé par exemple que les
avocats
qui étaient des nationaux du Royaume-Uni
qui soit représentaient des victimes,
soit travaillaient au sein du bureau du
procureur avait été averti par leur
ministère des affaires étrangères qu'ils
devaient cesser parce qu'ils allaient
être la cible de sanction et d'opération
de représaille décidé aux États-Unis sur
demande d'Israël. Pour vous donner un
exemple, là on parle de personnes qui
jouent une fonction officielle au sein
d'une procédure. On parle pas de
militants, d'activistes, encore moins de
de personnes qui participeraient aux
activités de la branche armée ou
politique, même du Hamas, du Esbola ou
quoi que ce soit quand vous et à
Forceori donc des terroristes là, vous
êtes dans une situation euh enfin j'aime
pas le terme, j'aime jamais le terme de
terrorisme parce que c'est un moyen de
terrorisme. Donc ça ça qualifie pas une
personne en tant que telle, mais en tout
cas des personnes qui font usage de
moyens terroristes.
On est dans une situation où notre
mouvement par exemple sur le conflit
israopalestinien. Revenons sur les
anglais. Oui. Et donc donc il se retire
une trace de tout ça. Il se retire. Ah
oui oui. Bah ça c'était comme je vous le
disais c'est dans un un article du
Guardian. les sanctions qui ont été
enfin je sais pas si vous rendez compte
les trois juges de la Cour pénale
nationale qui s'occupent de la situation
palestinienne et Dieu sait si je suis
critique de la Cour pé internationale et
si je considère le bureau du procureur
comme partiellement responsable de la
dérive à laquelle on est en train
d'assister aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
étaient la première fois que la
Palestine les saisie c'est en 2009 et
ils n'ont rien fait jusqu'en 2024 à rien
pendant 15 ans. Et c'est une inaction
organisée par l'acheter et par peur. Et
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
où donc même les juges chargés de la
situation palestinienne et donc des
mandats d'arrêt contre Benjamin
Netaniaou et Joav Galant euh sont sous
sanction américaines, ne peuvent plus
avoir de compte en banque et ainsi de
suite. Euh le les mails Microsoft
euh du procureur de la CPI ont été
suspendu. C'est là là aussi moi j'avais
prévenu il y a plusieurs années, j'ai
dit comment est-ce que vous pouvez vous
mettre entre les mains de Microsoft en
sachant parfaitement qu'il y a une
législation états-unienne qui fait que
ils ont droit à un accès immédiat alors
même les États-Unis ne font pas partie
du statut de Rome de la CPI. vous mettez
entre les mains d'un acteur qui à un
moment donné va vouloir vous flinguer
soit parce que vous allez enquêter en
Afghanistan ou en Palestine. Donc ça se
réduit et en parallèle Israël participe
aux procédures alors même qu'ils ne sont
pas partis du statut de Rome et commence
à dire "Ah non mais vous avez pas fait
telle notification, je sais pas quoi."
Il commence à chercher des difficultés
de procédure pour donner
une raison à la courationale de lâcher
l'affaire. d'annuler les mandats
d'arrêt, voyez, de de reculer. Pourquoi
? Parce que les mandats d'arrêt,
pourquoi ils sont embêtants ? Parce
qu'ils empêchent Netaniaou de survoler
ou de s'opposer sur 125 États. Et on l'a
vu, il a survolé la France, ça posait
pas de problème. Et on l'a vu quand il a
survolé trois fois la France ces
derniers mois après avoir contourné bien
d'autres États européens, l'Espagne et
ainsi de suite, qui eux respectaient
leurs obligations du statut de Rome
tandis que les autorités françaises
n'osaient pas le faire. Ça c'est on
reviendra sur ces questions et je pense
que ça serait bien qu'on parle de ce
conflit. On peut parler on peut en
parler tout de suite ? Le leur le Oui,
mais juste pour finir, leur idée c'est
de réduire le poule de personnes qui à
un moment donné vont avoir le courage de
répondre et de dire non non, ces
arguments de procédure ne sont pas
justes. Et vont du coup donner de la
nourriture au juges pour qu'ils puissent
continuer, vous voyez, et qu'ils
puissent avancer sur leur chemin. Et
donc à un moment donné, à ce niveau-là,
vous êtes immédiatement quand quand vous
n'êtes plus que 10, c'est aussi l'autre
problème, vous êtes immédiatement ciblé.
Si on a plus que 10, c'est très facile
de s'occuper de chacun d'entre eux
individuellement. Voyez, il y a plus
vraiment de et et et donc donc quand par
ailleurs, moi je pense que il y a une
instrumentalisation très importante de
ce conflit en France de toute part
extraordinairement violente. On a essayé
on en a fait un un conflit
intracommunautaire en France.
C'est-à-dire que il y a une mobilisation
de force politiques de toute forme, de
médias aussi dans le but d'en faire un
sujet de politique intérieure, ce qui
est vraiment dangereux. Euh mais en
réalité quand vous voyez les positions
sur le conflit en lui-même, même la
France insoumise reste sur une position
classique de solutions à deux états et
ainsi de suite. Donc qui n'est pas
fondamentalement dangereuse pour les
intérêts de l'État d'Israël tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui. notre position c'est
qu'il faut abandonner la solution à deux
états, que c'est fini, c'est qu'on est
dans une situation où il n'y aura plus
de possibilité d'effectiver ce qui est
devenu une pure un pur fantasme et qu'il
va falloir reconstruire reconstituer une
forme de Palestine historique que tout
le monde puisse vivre, qu'il soit juif,
chrétien, musulman, arabe, tout ce que
vous enfin selon que vous définissiez
selon des configurations ethniques ou
religieuses atées euh sous une tutelle
qui soit soit soit sur un modèle
libanais, c'estàd une répartition des
pouvoirs selon les confessions, selon
les les rapports de force existants,
mais aussi selon la représentativité des
communautés, soit sous une tutelle
internationale. On le papier que vous
nous avez montré, ça représente quoi ?
Il y a combien de pages ? Et vous
demandez quoi à l'intérieur ? Donc là,
c'est justement c'est une réponse. La la
Cour nous a demandé de réagir euh aux
quelques-uns qui restent à une demande
de l'État d'Israël de mettre fin en
procédure. Donc ça vous êtes
automissionné ou on vous a on est venu
vous chercher. Voilà. Moi, moi je
représente c'est là aussi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on est peu nombreux ? parce
que je représente des victimes de Gaza
mais qui sont encore aujourd'hui à Gaza.
Donc vous imaginez bien que rentrer en
contact avec des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui dans la situation
apocalyptique que l'on connaît sans
moyen de communication avec les moyens
de communication qui restent
complètement surveillés et contrôlés par
Israël qui n'hésite pas, on l'a vu, à
tuer qui que ce soit qui pourrait
présenter un danger ou une menace pour
leurs intérêts directes ou indirect avec
leur lieu d'habitation. leur papier
d'identité, les preuves qu'il pourrait
constituer complètement détruit avec une
capacité à les transmettre vers
l'extérieur difficile. Euh c'est c'est
déjà particulièrement compliqué. J'ai
réussi, on a réussi après un long
travail exfiltré un certain nombre de
personnes de Gaza, notamment des
Marocains, des une famille marocaine qui
n'avait pas du tout été assistée par le
royaume du Maroc dont on a découvert
récemment. Ça, je tiens quand même à le
dire, même si on va finir par penser que
j'ai quelque chose contre le royaume du
le roi du Maroc, ce qui est pas du tout
le cas, qu'il a des programmes de
d'entraînement militaire avec Israël.
parce que l'une des l'un des soldats
marocains qui participait est mort
pendant les échanges de tirs de domicile
qu'il y a eu entre l'Iran et Israël ces
dernières semaines. Euh donc on a on
fait un travail de fond de fourmis,
c'est sourcé ça le silencieux. Oui oui.
Silencieux qui consiste en fait à
essayer de Oui. Parce que enfin bref, on
pourrait revenir sur ce point spécifique
qui est intéressant parce que c'est
révélateur de de l'hypocrisie de de nos
dirigeants de façon générale, mais aussi
de plus en plus en particulier des
dirigeants des pays arabes à l'égard de
ce conflit parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
la responsabilité de l'Occident et ainsi
de suite comme si on était encore la
puissance tutellaire sur la région. de
la réalité, c'est qu'il y a une
complaisance voir une compromission très
importante de la part des régimes
politiques, que ce soit du Maghreb à
l'exception de l'Algérie et encore parce
que l'action algérienne est relativement
faible au-delà des mots mais les autres
c'est encore plus aggravé et évidemment
du moyen et du du Moyen-Orient et du
Golfe. Donc on se retrouve dans une
situation où non seulement
on est peu nombreux du fait des menaces,
mais on est aussi peu nombreux du fait
que tout simplement les victimes ont du
mal à échanger avec des personnes
extérieures. On ont peur de se faire
représenter au sein de la CPI, ont peur
des conséquences que cela pourrait
avoir. n'ont pas grand-chose à gagner et
donc ça ouvre la porte à ce que Israël
arrive avec ses gros sabots et disent
voilà article 192 du traité, les
conditions n'ont pas été du statut de
Rome n'ont pas été respectées, il faut
faire sauter la chose et donc nous on se
retrouve avec à titre complètement
probono à faire ce travail de fourmis
qui consiste à essayer de donc là en
l'occurrence c'est 50 pages qui ont été
qui ont été produites qui consiste à
répondre à cet argumentaire c'est sur le
suivant les la demande de la chambre
pour essayer
de remettre en perspective, de contrer
l'analyse procédurale qui était portée
par l'État Israël, mais surtout montrer
et faire pression sur les juges en
disant "On vous regarde, on est là et
n'oubliez pas que on existe." Et quand
je dis on, c'est évidemment la
population palestinienne à Gaza. Et et
ce qui m'a aussi de le rappeler, c'est
que euh c'est pas seulement la
population palestinienne,
c'est le devenir de l'humanité. Parce
que ce qui est en train de se passer
avec l'Iran la tentative par Israël de
faire tomber le régime iranien parce que
c'est ça ce qui s'est passé c der
semaine he il faut pas se tromper sur
ils sont quand même en bisbiit depuis un
certain nombre d'années ça se finance
des groupes armés à gauche à droite ça
infiltre à gauche à droite. Ils sont
quand même un petit peu énervés tous les
deux. Je sais pas ce qu'on aurait pensé
s'il y avait une tentative d'assassinat
ou de Netaniaahu
mise en œuvre par l'Iran ces dernières
semaines et qu'est-ce que ça aurait
légitimé en retour ? Moi je pense que
moi j'ai une position très radicale sur
la question. La duclisation de la région
c'est important.
Elle conditionne Elle est conditionnée
par quoi ? Par la dénuclarisation
d'Israël. C'est moi je renverse
complètement la position historique qui
a été adoptée par la France qui a aidé
Israël à obtenir la bombe nucléaire.
Quelle force politique aujourd'hui dit
ça en France ? Vous voyez ? Et c'est pas
c'est une radicalité d'apparence. C'est
une radicalité par rapport à ce qui est
devenu la norme, l'acceptation d'un état
de fait qui est absolument aberrent.
Comment vous voulez exiger
un peuple et un régime ? Parce que ce
n'est pas qu'un régime l'Iran, c'est un
peuple et c'est un pays de 100 millions
d'habitants qui a des frontières avec la
Turquie et donc le Kurdistan avec des
menaces de séparatisme très important
avec l'Irak, avec l'Afghanistan et le
régime taliban, avec le Okaraba et dont
le devenir de l'Arménie est en jeu à
partir de ce qui joue sur l'Iran et
évidemment avec le D3 d'ormous. Donc je
veux dire une déstabilisation
avec un régime change de l'Iran, tel
qu'il a été mise en œuvre en Irak et en
Afghanistan, c'est une bombe nucléaire.
C'est une bombe nucléaire littéralement.
C'est-à-dire c'est la possibilité d'une
catastrophe à l'échelle régionale. Et
avec quelle alternative ? L'héritier du
Chat d'Iran qui je pense doit avoir 70
de cuit et qui et qui est poussé par
Netaniaou. Non, c'est important. C'estàd
que vous avez fait une évaluation de son
cuit. Vous l' vous avez vu la promotion
qui en est faite dans un certain nombre
de médias français mais aussi je ne veux
pas entendre. Il a lien avec Nathanahu
et donc Netaniaou quand il vise euh la
prison des vines,
quel est l'objectif a trois français qui
sont au français. Ouais. Quel est
l'objectif de Netaniau ? c'est
déstabiliser le régime en produisant une
fuite massive de prisonniers qui
accompagnait des bombardements,
rappelons de la télé nationale
iranienne. On a détruit des décennies
d'archives particulièrement importantes,
un p de la culture et de l'histoire
iranienne particulièrement important. On
n'est pas allé attaquer seulement soit
des usines de fabrication de missiles,
soit les sites d'enrichissement
d'uranium. Je me fais la défense
d'Israël. On a attaqué à un organe de
propagande qui s'édate sa population et
qui et qui est vecteur du du de la
parole officielle. Donc vous légitimez
le bombardement de journaliste. Je ne
légitime rien du tout. Je me mets à la
place d'Israël. Israël a dû dire ça.
Non. Donc enfin vous vous rappelez quand
on a bombardé la télé publique Serpe ?
Ouais bien sûr. Là aussi avec des
pseudos débats. Est-ce que en droit
international voyez tout d'un coup comme
ça devient débattable. Ah mais peut-être
qu'on peut assassiner des journalistes.
C'est peut-être pas si mal que ça. Vous
voyez, c'est un peu là ce qui se passe
avec l'Ukraine et et la décision de
Zelinski de renoncer à la convention
interdisant les les pardon, je je suis
un peu fatigué, les les
mines antipersonnelles.
Ça c'est intéressant, non ? Est-ce que
vous avez vu un communiqué d'amnestie ou
ainsi de suite ? Est-ce que vous avez vu
des dépêches sur le sujet ? Zelinski a
annoncé le retrait de l'Ukraine de la
convention interdisant les mines
antipersonnelles. Là, il y a une raison
objective
beaucoup plus légitimante que celle que
vous venez d'évoquer à l'égard de non,
c'est que les Russes eux ne sont pas
partis à cette convention et que donc il
y a en effet un déséquilibre euh sur le
terrain de guerre. Mais à quel moment au
lieu nos chancelleries, nos médias, nos
ONG, ainsi de suite, au lieu de gueuler
comme des putois pour dire non seulement
tu vas y rester, mais on va faire un
effort extraordinaire pour essayer de
contraindre ou d'essayer d'inciter la
Russie à le ratifier, le signer et voir
quel engagement on peut prendre pour
qu'on retour et ainsi de suite. Non,
non. Oui, c'est vrai. Pourquoi pas ? En
fait, on est en train quand on parle
d'envagement du monde, enfin pardon,
mais en fait, il y a une sorte de
disparition des limites sur l'ordre
international. le droit international,
on accepte. Je reviens à Nathalie
Yambble.
Nathalie Gamb, la seule chose qu'elle a
fait cette femme qui en effet a une une
audience extraordinaire en Afrique
francophone, on se rend pas compte et là
aussi on se rend pas compte de ce qu'on
est en train de faire et à quel point on
est en train de jouer avec le diable
avec ce sujet qui a participé à une
conférence
financée ou organisée, elle n'a pas été
payée par une ONG qui dit-on serait
rattachée à Wagner sur la liberté
d'expression en compagnie. une
conférence il y a il y a 3 4 ans euh qui
par ailleurs a donné des discours à Soi
a fait une demi-douzaine de déplacements
en Russie comme elle l'en fait un peu
partout dans le monde euh et où elle a
donné des discours qui sont
particulièrement radicaux contre
l'ingérence occidentale en Afrique.
D'accord.
Cette personne-là qui est Suisse, qui se
qui habite en Suisse retrouve sans aucun
processus contradictoire,
interdite d'entrée et de transit sur le
territoire de l'Union européenne et avec
l'ensemble de ses avoirs gelés
comme ça. Et si elle veut contester la
mesure devant le tribunal de l'Union
européenne, la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne. Et c'est ce qu'on va
devoir faire. Non seulement
théoriquement là, elle ne peut même plus
revenir parce que là il y a tout un
débat, on est en train d'essayer de
régler ça avec le département suisse qui
qui s'occupe de des affaires étrangères,
savoir si elle a le droit quand même de
survoler l'espace aérien. Visiblement,
Netaniaou a le droit Netania a le droit.
Donc pourquoi est-ce que ce ne serait
pas son cas ? Sérieusement, il a y a il
y a des enjeux à ce niveau-là par
rapport à la convention de Chicago ?
Notice non, elle a elle n'a commis aucun
acte délictueux criminel. Est-ce qu'il y
a eu une enquête sur elle ? Est-ce que
est-ce qu'on a remonté ses filières de
d'approvision France a demandé ça à la
haute représentant ? que la France a
fourni des preuves auprès que maente sur
ses finances, sur qui elle voyait sur
ses écout à moins que ma cliente mente à
son avocat et je pense que ce serait une
très mauvaise idée de sa part et je
pense pas qu'elle qu'elle commette cette
erreur. Elle n'a jamais reçu un copec un
rouble de la de la Russie. Donc à partir
de là, il aurait peut-être passé, il
serait peut-être passé par un autre pays
par un ter enfin ou il faut l'établir.
Mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
y a pas il y a rien. Il y a pas de
processus contradictoire. Il y a juste
une décision de quatre lignes en disant
des liens avec Afrique. Donc cette
conférence à Berlin où encore une fois
des députés étaient et donc ben allez,
tu peux plus rentrer chez toi. Enfin, on
ne sait pas si tu rentres peut-être
qu'il y a un risque qu'il se passe
quelque chose que le enfin dans une que
ton que ton vol soit détourné. Enfin, on
est on est dans une situation qui est
quand même délirante et tu peux
contester ça va prendre un an, 2 ans, on
verra tant pis pour toi. Tout ça
pourquoi ? pour avoir tenu des discours.
Tenu des discours, c'est un peu comme
les armements qu'on a envoyé en Ukraine
en prenant appui sur le fond pour la
paix, enfin le fond européen pour la
paix, vous voyez ? Enfin, le le paradoxe
extraordinaire. Moi, il y a un moment
donné où euh on donne des leçons à la
terre entière et on est incapable de
faire respecter nos principes
fondamentaux, donc droits
contradictoires, droit de la défense,
droit d'avoir une explication un peu
détaillée de ce qu'on vous reproche, de
pouvoir s'en justifier avant de se
retrouver avec une sanction qui est
quand même quasiment plus violente que
se retrouver en prison par certains
aspects. Tout d'un coup, vous êtes vous
pouvez pas rentrer sur le territoire qui
est le vôtre. Enfin, vous voyez. Et la
Suisse qui pour l'instant dit "Ah bah je
suis un peu ou ils sont un peu gênés."
Oui. Donc, mais on prend des risques en
tant que Union européenne parce que les
Suisses nous avaient suivi sur les
premiers trains de sanction contre des
oligares russes, contre des gens comme
Prigogine et ainsi de suite. Euh, ils
ont arrêté. Ils ont arrêté parce que il
y a plus de 1500 personnes maintenant
qui sont sur sanction et ils voi que ça
part qu'on se trompe qu'il y a des gens
on s'est trompé sur leur identité. Euh
d'autres c'était la maire de Prigogine,
d'autres c'est enfin des on part sur des
des des absences de d'exigences non
seulement de la part de l'institution
européenne parce que tout ça pas passe
par le coréère, c'est-à-dire en gros par
le Conseil de l'Union européenne, c'est
les ministres des affaires étrangères
réunis en en section après les
ambassadeurs qui doivent voter à
l'unanimité le le train de sanction. Euh
et ensuite le tribunal, l'Union
européenne est censé euh permettre un
contrôle à des délais complètement
délirants, un coût très important.
Parmi les exceptions euh à son
autorisation à faire des transactions
avec des Européens, j'ai trouvé ça un
peu un peu mignon et et drôle, c'est
elle peut payer des avocats euh si
tenter que leurs honoraires soient
raisonnables. Ce qui a un peu frustré
mes ambitions, mais euh vous voyez, tout
est tout est dans une sorte de en fait
de prise de contrôle progressive
euh
de rognement de nos principes qui font
qu'on on perd. C'est un rognement de nos
principes ou c'est une militarisation de
nos principes ? parce qu'on est en état
de guerre parce qu'il y a des ingérences
à gauche à droite. C'est quoi c'est quoi
la souscence de tout ça ? C'est c'est
quoi ? C'est qu'on serait en guerre avec
la Russie, ce qui n'est pas le cas.
Voyez, c'est quand même ça ressemble
quand même un peu. Voilà, c'est ça.
C'est que aujourd'hui, on se comporte
comme si on était en guerre et notre
appareil d'État
donne à croire que nous sommes en guerre
avec la Russie alors que nous le sommes
pas et que la Russie avec les 1000
défauts de ce régime et de son
comportement géopolitique est très
attentive, très attentive à ne pas
dépasser les limites à notre égard, ce
qui est moins notre cas. Et on joue avec
à Felant. Alors, peut-être qu'on se dit
qu'on a une telle supériorité militaire
avec le temps et ainsi de suite sur eux
et ainsi de suite que il y a pas il y a
pas d'inquiétude à avoir quand quant aux
conséquences que ça pourrait déclencher.
La réalité c'est que on est sur une
bordure qui m'inquiète beaucoup qui fait
que la paix est menacée en France de la
même façon que notre comportement au
Moyen-Orient m'est apparu en conséquent.
N'oubliez jamais que la France a proposé
de participer à guerre à Gaza
initialement avec Netaniaou en proposant
la constitution d'une coalition
internationale. Qu'on se retrouver à ça
de se retrouver en première ligne sur un
conflit régional qui aurait très vite
débordé que là euh ça s'est joué à pas
grand-chose avec l'Iran. Heureusement
que les Chinois, les Russes sont
intervenus pour essayer de calmer la
folie de Netanyahu et et des et des
États-Unis et qu' on est en train en
fait de de jouer avec des dynamiques qui
pourront très rapidement nous faire
basculer dans dans l'irréversible.
N'oubliez pas qu'Israël a aujourd'hui
autant de bombes nucléaires que nous.
Ils ont pas que 90 têtes. Non,
apparemment officieusement ils en
auraient plus de 200 désormais. On est
sur une situation en fait au moment où
on part
sur l'étape de trop, il y a plus de
marche arrière et nous on aura pas de
marche de manœuvre à ce moment-là. Donc
vous êtes pas en train de me décrire le
fait qu'on rentre en guerre contre
Israël. Ben on peut pas parce que
dissuasion on s'en est on s'en est rendu
incapable même si on le voulait. Et
c'est pour ça qu'en fait il il y a
plusieurs facteurs hein. Il y a il y a
le fait qu'il y a 400000 français en
Israël. Donc c'est quand même une
communauté énorme énorme qui fait que
c'est très compliqué de prendre des
positions qui soient qui soient très à
l'opposé de de du gouvernement place y
compris lorsqu'il est extrémiste comme
actuellement. Mais n'oubliez pas ça
c'est très important le soutien massif
dont bénéficie Netania aujourd'hui au
sein de la société israélienne. C'estd
qu'en fait il faut aussi qu'on actualise
notre doctrine par rapport à cet état de
fait. Aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui Israël
suit Netaniaou. Aujourd'hui, la société
israélienne est d'accord avec ce que
Netaniaou fait en Iran et d'accord avec
ce que Netaniaou fait à Gaza. Il y a pas
de dissociation possible comme le point
l'a tenté il y a quelques semaines.
Aujourd'hui, il y a une responsabilité
collective et la tentation Israéliens ne
sont pas d'accord avec la politique de
Nethania ou plus de 80 % plus de 80 %
des pardon pardon plus de 80 % c'est
dernier sondage.
Si vous enlevez les Arabes israéliens
évidemment, mais il y a à peu près 85 %
des juifs israéliens qui appuient la
politique de Netaniaou à Gaza selon le
dernier sondage qui était publié un mois
interne. Donc on est sur une situation
où il y a quand même un massacre de
grand ampleur mais surtout une véléité
explicitée
de vider Gaza de sa population arabe et
palestinienne. C'est ça l'objectif. Donc
on est sur une situation qui euh est
extraordinaire. C'estàd qu'on a qualifié
de génocide à Sbrenitsa le fait d'avoir
tué quelques milliers de personnes après
les avoir séparé des femmes et enfants
pour ne tuer que les hommes. Là on est
sur une situation d'une ampleur
incomparable et on continue à nier qu'il
y a une problématique majeure. On est
dans l'incapacité de rompre nos
relations diplomatiques avec l'État
d'Israël. On est dans l'incapacité de le
faire arrêter lorsqu'il survole le
territoire
français. Et on est surtout dans la
capacité de faire autre chose que
d'affirmer que l'on défendra le droit
d'Israël à se défendre en cas de
représaille contre les bombardements qui
avaient été initiés par Israël sans à
aucun moment avoir d'abord condamné des
bombardements Israël. Et on est dans
l'incapacité de dire il faut en effet
éviter que l'Iran devienne une puissance
nucléaire et il faut qu'Israël renonce à
sa la position de l'Espagne par rapport
à la France c'est diamétralement opposé
pas diamètr elle a reconnu l'état l'état
de Palestine contrairement à la France
ça c'était intéressant non
Macron a vraiment de la chance d'avoir
séjourné un système médiatique aussi
aussi à server et et surtout médiocrisé
parce que je pense que
jamais honnêtement jamais la France n'a
eu un président de la République aussi
pitoyable dans les relations
internationales. Jamais la France n'a eu
un président de la République qui a de
façon si systématique raté toutes les
initiatives qu'il prenait à l'échelle
internationale. C'est quand même
quelqu'un pour revenir sur la RDC, le
Ronda qui a nommé à la tête de
l'Organisation internationale de la
francophonie une randaise alors même que
le Ronda venait de renoncer à la France
comme langue officielle sur son
territoire. Je sais pas si vous rendez
compte de la folie de la chose.
C'est-àdire que vous avez un pays qui
était francophone qui décide de basculer
sur l'anglais et pour le remercier le
récompenser, vous nommez un ministre
rond euh comme euh dirigeant de
l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie. C'est ça aujourd'hui,
c'est euh c'est un p un pays qui a perdu
soit rompu diplomatique avec euh un
certain nombre d'États africain, le
Niger, euh la ES qui a perdu l'estime
des populations ouest-africaines de
façon structurelle, qui a eu une crise
majeure avec la RDC au point où 10 le
président en place s'amuse à recevoir
tout le monde de Mélenchon jusqu'à
bientôt la bard des là. Vous vous rendez
compte ? Tout ça par détestation
d'Emmanuel Macron. quelqu'un qui au
Liban avait euh euh donné des leçons
dans tous les sens en disant on va
reconstituer euh le Liban, on va tout
réorganiser, c'est nous qui allons tout
faire et qui s'est ridiculisé dans les
grandes largeurs. Quelqu'un qui a
proposé une coalition internationale à
Netaniau pour faire commettre les
massacres qu'il a comme à Gaza.
Quelqu'un qui a fait des allers-retours
auprès de Poutine et de et de monsieur
Zelenski en prétendant qu'il allait
résoudre le ou empêcher le conflit puis
après qu'il allait résoudre et ainsi de
suite. quelqu'un qui s'est mis à genoux
devant Donald Trump après avoir prétendu
que c'était un grand danger. Bon bref,
je pourrais sur l'ensemble des questions
fondamentales dont nous avons eu à
traiter, heureusement qu'on a encore une
fois un appareil diplomatique encore un
peu solide, qu'on reste une puissance de
facto et qu'on a réussi à éviter un
effondrement à ce stade. Mais en
réalité, il est déjà partiellement là.
Encore une fois, en Afrique, c'est une
catastrophe. en en 8 ans, il a provoqué
quelque chose qui était inimaginable.
Inimaginable et qui va être très très
difficile à rattraper. C'est pour ça
aussi qu'il faut qu'on se prépare
rapidement parce que il y a qui ont bah
c'est que les forces politiques qui
cherchent à s'y opposer. Nous, celle
qu'on a constitué à travers l'initiative
qu'on vous avait présenté la dernière
fois qui s'appelle comment ? Qui
s'appelle Aurore et qu'on on a constitué
des ruches un peu sur tout le
territoire. L'objectif, c'est évidemment
euh de proposer une doctrine
alternative, de sortir la solution à
deux états sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien.
Enfin, je veux dire, qui y croit encore
sérieusement ? Et qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on est on reste bloqué sur une
solution fictionnelle qui nous met en
fait dans une position d'impuissance et
d'absence de crédibilité absolue. Voyez,
il y a un moment donné, il faut évoluer,
il faut avancer et il faut accepter le
fait que notre position constante va pas
se retrouver en cohérence avec le réel
pendant un temps. Pourquoi ? parce que
ce sera impossible d'avancer vers autre
chose pendant x années, mais on aura
raison à la fin et on aura été justement
pionnier et on aura permis d'ouvrir les
portes, ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui. On va pas faire une grande
interview aujourd'hui parce que vous
êtes fatigué et puis je pense que vous
êtes vous avez pris quand même sacrément
sur le car à fond en Afrique.
Politique intérieure française, vous
vous présentez au présidentiel, vous
allez être le faiseur de roi. Est-ce que
vous allez vous allier à d'autres camp
ou est-ce que vous allez faire cavalier
seul ?
Je suis assez inquiet par
le chemin que prend Dominique de
Villepin. Inquié pourquoi ? Parce que
Dominique de Villepin, c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui euh qui part avec un
certain nombre de pas du tout de
casseroles mais de de handicap. Déjà, il
a pas de base électorale. Voilà, il a il
a pas de base électorale, il a pas
d'ancrage territorial en France. il a
une idée fantasmatique de la France. il
a euh une un bilan sur la politique
intérieure française qui est vraiment
fragile, les notamment avec ce point
fondamental, les autoroutes, voilà, mais
aussi un certain nombre de mesures
économiques par ailleurs qui ont été
particulièrement contestables. Euh
il a une intelligence phénoménale, une
culture extraordinaire et il a une idée
pour la France et une idée de la France
en tout cas. en France et ce qui lui
manque, ce que j'ai toujours considéré
et et qui lui avait manqué, quelqu'un
que je connais très très bien, c'est
l'articulation entre une politique
extérieure et une politique intérieure.
Les deux doivent aller ensemble. C'est
fondamental de réfléchir ensemble cette
articulation là. Si vous réfléchissez
pas par exemple à des questions comme le
nombre de Français en Israël, enfin
voyez ces questions-là sont
fondamentales pour essayer d'avoir une
politique cohérente. Euh il il a pour
tenter de palier à son banque d'encrage
territorial lancer un parti déjà qui
s'appelle la France humaniste. Alors
déjà le titre en soi est un peu
inquiétant parce que je suis désolé mais
ça raisonne pas pour quelqu'un qui
justement a une difficulté à à
s'approcher ou à s'accrocher des
Français. Là, on reste sur des idées
extraordinairement vagues et ainsi de
suite. Qui n'a pas compris que les
Français avaient un besoin de protection
très important aujourd'hui, de
souveraineté au sens le plus serré du
terme. C'est ça l'enjeu de la prochaine
présidentielle et que l'espace est
complètement laissé vacant par le
Rassemblement national à cet égard. On a
ensuite une difficulté sur les choix des
personnes qui l'accompagnent. Le
président du parti qui l'a choisi,
Benoir Cénz, maire de Gargonnais, c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a aucun charisme au-delà
d'avoir aucune autorité, ainsi de suite.
C'est quelqu'un qui n'incarne rien. Donc
en fait si fait bien son travail ce à
quoi à Gor je les connais, c'est pas la
même chose que d'être président du parti
de la France politique qui va qui va
diriger la France. Non, mais c'est pas
du tout du méprise que je dis. C'est une
c'est pas du tout à l'égard de monsieur
Jimenez le problème, c'est à l'égard de
l'autosabotage que je vois déjà
commencer à se mettre en œuvre chez cet
homme qui pourtant porte des aspirations
importantes chez une partie de la
population et qui pourrait préposer une
voie médiane entre la marginalisation
croissante que connaît la France
insoumise et la trahison absolue que
propose leur Assemblée nationale y
compris par rapport à leurs propres
idéaux et ce bloc central dont quand
même notre objectif commun devrait
d'éviter à tout prix
qu'il se remettent au pouvoir et qu'il
recrée une figure similaire à celle de
Macron pour nous imposer 5 à 10 ans de
plus parce qu'entre-temps c'est des vies
qui sont détruites et c'est des
espérances de vie au pluriel pour les
Français qui sont dévastées et donc dans
cette configuration là
j'ai peur que tout soit t trop sclérosé
pardon pour que la reconfiguration
intervienne avant 2027 mois à quel point
il est compliqué de constituer une force
politique. Je je le vis depuis plusieurs
mois, je vois à quel point la discipline
et la loyauté par exemple sont des
valeurs qui ont un peu disparu au sein
de la société française en général. Ça
c'est un enjeu fondamental aussi. Il
faut que on réfléchisse tous à notre
responsabilité dans notre situation.
C'est très bien de projeter sur les
politiciens, c'est très bien de dire
Macron c'est le diable et ainsi de
suite. Et à un moment donné, cette
société française s'est quand même
dégradée voire décomposée partiellement
et il va falloir reconstituer par la
base. Or si les bases ont perdu
justement leur structure, leur capacité
à à construire, elles se retrouvent dans
une situation où elles-mêmes ne sont
c'est difficile pour elles de porter un
alan nouveau. Et donc là, nous on essae
comme on le peut avec les 17000
personnes, c'est quand même pas mal qui
nous qui nous ont rejoint, d'essayer de
de modeler cela. Mais ça prend du temps,
ça prend beaucoup de temps. Il faut de
l'humilité, de la patience. Il faut
accepter que quand on n'a pas d'argent,
quand on va pas chercher dans des
circuits de corruption habituels, dans
les grandes entreprises, des grandes
fortunes et ainsi de suite, ça requiert
d'autant plus d'efforts. Mais ce que les
gens ne sont pas habitués à se voir
demander dans l'espace politique,
surtout dans les espaces contestataires
parce que on est très fort pour
critiquer, on est très fort pour se
plaindre mais quand il s'agit de
nous-même commencer à organiser des
choses et à construire, à montrer qu'on
est meilleur que les autres, là on se
rend compte que c'est pas si évident que
ça. Vous voyez ? Donc il faut il faut
cette cette et et al campagne qui
consiste,
je vois avec aussi la France insoumise
qui qui a un modèle un peu plus hybride
mais qui dans le fond a cette tentation
qu'on a vu typiquement avec la mise en
scène du bateau de Rima Hassan et ainsi
de suite que qui est quelqu'un en plus
que j'ai toujours défendu contre toutes
les attaques qu'elle a pu recevoir pour
ne serait-ce que pour une seule raison.
Elle est palestinienne, donc elle est
parfaitement légitime à en faire le
combat de sa vie et à y émettre son
cœur. Oui. Et en fait ce que je pensais
c'est que cette femme avec cet
engagement de cœur et du coup avec cette
radicalité que ça lui a donné au sens
noble du terme serait en mesure même
presque de changer le pays si elle
étendait son discours à la France dans
son ensemble. Voyez, si à partir de
cette base d'indignation et elle reste
un peu bloquée dans cette perspective là
et on voit Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
commence à se refermer sur lui-même,
voyez, avoir une forme de réflexe. Qui
est-ce qui a financé la flotille de Rima
Hassan ?
J'ai que des informations
euh de source unique donc en fait qui
n'ont pas été contrasté donc je vais pas
les donner mais pour moi c'est une
erreur symbolique le voilier. Euh on va
on va passer sur ceux qui ont ironie le
ironisé sur le diesel et compagnie nana.
Euh et ce qui était euh en fait si vous
regardez ça avec un peu de distance, ça
va. Mais si vous suiviez de près euh la
petite histoire au quotidien avec euh la
fausse attaque de drone avec euh attaque
de drone, c'était pas une attaque de
drone, c'était des drones de Frontex euh
sur les eaux territoriales grecs. Des
drones qui leur vaporisaient des choses
sur le bateau. Non non, ça il y a eu une
vaporisation au moment où ils sont où
ils ont été arraisonnés. Ils ont été
araisonnés dans les eaux internationales
ou dans les eaux ce que j'ai compris
dans les eaux internationales. Donc il y
a tout un débat sur en fait les eaux
limitrophes et la possibilité
d'intervenir un peu au-delà. Mais quoi
qu'il arrive en fait il y a une
difficulté de départ c'est que Israël
enfin n'a pas un contrôle effectif sur
le territoire et des obligations à cet
égard le territoire de Gaza mais c'est
pas des eaux israéliennes. Enfin même si
c'était rapproché donc et qu'importe
tout ça c'est de la broutille. L'enjeu
c'était, j'ai bien vu et c'est là où ça
m'a un peu gêné, c'était de jouer sur le
symbolisme de la flottique de Gaza de
2010 dans mon souvenir, les morts qui
avaient eu lieu parce que c'était des
militants turcs et ainsi de suite pour
prétendre qu'il y avait un risilaire
alors même qu'en fait il y avait une
protection immense du fait de leur
statut, de leur médiatisation, de leur
qualité de européen qui joue énormément
et surtout de la coordination immédiate
qui s'était mise en place entre les
autorités françaises israéliennes pour
traiter de façon et en fait c'est je
m'en fiche
C'est pas un problème, j'ai pas de
jugement à porter. C'est le c'est que
entre-temps, il y avait des Palestiniens
qui étaient en train de se faire
bombarder alors qu'ils allaient
chercher à manger. Voyez, c'est c'est
pendant cette période qu'Israël a
commencé à bombarder les personnes qui
se concentraient sur le seul centre
d'aide alimentaire qui avait été rouvert
et qui est sous contrôle israélien après
avoir évacué toutes les dispositions
humanitaires. Et on faisait de l'enhase
et de l'émotion
au mauvais endroit. Je vous voyez ? Et
en fait, il y avait une forme d'effet de
substitution qui qui m'est apparu
relativement déplacé. Vous conseillez de
recevoir Rima Hassan ou pas ?
Moi, je pense que c'est très important
en fait de la pousser à ne serait-ce que
pour la pousser à ouvrir son discours.
Il faut que cette femme parle de France
parce que elle est elle est elle est
intelligente, elle incarne quelque chose
pour beaucoup de Français. Vous
connaissez, on va faire l'avocat du
diable. Et il y a beaucoup de Mais il y
a beaucoup de Français qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ne parlent pas
d'eux. Et en fait à un moment donné je
peux comprendre
la souffrance de du de ne pas avoir
enfin il y a quelque chose qu'en fait
beaucoup de d'exilés peuvent connaître
vous voyez de de ne pas avoir connu sa
terre d'origine et la nécessité d'y
revenir et et ça et ça peut développer
en fait une force politique très
importante. Vous voyez ce besoin de se
réenraciner au moins d'être confronté
pour s'en libérer de pouvoir avoir mis
les pieds dessus. Mais il elle est une
élue du peuple français et elle doit
accompagner ce mouvement-là, ne
serait-ce que pour permettre ensuite à
la France à soumise de façon générale de
refuser des les et de bloquer les
attaques dont ils font l'objet, qui les
marginalisent et qui les mettent dans
une position intenable. Aujourd'hui,
elle n'en est pas du tout responsable en
soi hein, mais je dis juste que je pense
que ça pourrait revenons en fait la
politique intérieure et Dominique de
Villepin et vos potentiels alliés ou pas
alliés.
Nous notre objectif c'est de construire
notre chemin. D'accord ? Parce que on a
une légitimité que d'autres n'ont pas à
travers un certain nombre d'engagement à
travers les gil jaunes ainsi. Il y a pas
une force politique. La France insoumise
était pas là. Reste au pied les autres
on en parle même pas. Euh par rapport à
aussi à l'engagement souverainiste, le
Rassemblement national qui a renoncé par
rapport à ouvrir ne serait-ce que le
débat sur l'Union européenne, sur
l'euro, sur les politiques monétaires.
C'est pas seulement la question de
l'appartenance à l'euro ou pas qui a
complè qui s'est complètement aligné sur
les politiques atlantistes par ailleurs.
Il faut à un moment donné, on est les
seuls à pouvoir proposer une forme de
quelque part de reconstitution d'une
puissance d'équilibre que serait la
France. Ça c'est sur le plan étranger et
en plan intérieur. Je suis désolé, on
est les seuls à vouloir mais couper la
tête à l'adre bureaucratique
administratif qui s'est développé, qui
est en train de nous empoisonner tous et
d'alléger de façon générale la charge
qui repose que ce soit sur les
employeurs ou les salariés. Tous, tous,
sans pour autant renoncer au services
publics. Au contraire, est-ce que ça
passera par arrêter de financer des
films qui font quelques dizaines ou
centaines de milliers d'entrées qui ne
servent à rien d'autre qu'à enrichir les
acteurs et réalisateurs qui contribuent
? Est-ce que ça passera par faire sauter
tous les dispositifs dont on avait parlé
la dernière fois, que ce soit ma prime
Renove, le CPF et ainsi de suite dont on
voit très bien comment ils sont détourné
dans le seul but de gonfler les poches
d'un certain nombre de personnes. Est-ce
que ça va faire du mal à des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui en fait
vivent de façon parasitaire en France ?
peut-être quelques millions, oui, mais
avec un soulagement, une respiration
pour la totalité des gens qui seraient
enfin enfin bienvenu. Est-ce qu'on
serait en mesure de porter ça dans le
temps qui nous est laissé ? Ça dépend de
chacun d'entre nous, ça dépend de notre
capacité à un moment donné à se coaguler
et à commencer vraiment à travailler.
Nous, on a fait un projet, un travail
énorme. Vous vous l'aviez parcouru, des
centaines de propositions hyper
détaillées. Ça a pris des années hein de
Il est sur le site d'Aurore aurore.org,
c'est très simple. été challengé par des
économistes, par d'autres politiciens.
Il Non, mais parce que
l'espace public français
la la suffisance et l'insuffisance de
ceux qui participent. Vous voyez cette
cette absence de délibération sur les
sujets de fond, on parle on parle de
on parle des vaguelettes quoi. On est en
train de se détruire et pardonnez-moi,
je pense y avoir contribué là par
exemple à parlant de la flottille. Je
j'aurais pas dû, voyez. Enfin, on reste
sur des sur des effets de surface qui
sont qui nous empêchent à un moment
donné euh de nous confronter vraiment
sur le fondement. Moi, je rêve, je rêve
mais de d'exploser,
d'exploser en débat euh euh Gabriel
Natal, euh Jordan Bardella et ainsi de
suite, voyez, de purger ces fausses
alternatives Édouard Philippe, mais
qu'on me le présente, qu'on me le
présente Édouard Philippe, qu'on qu'on
parle de son rapport à la dette, à la
retraite à 67 ans, qu'on on va jouer
ensemble, on va commencer à discuter de
son parcours, on va on va on va
commencer à confronter des regards sur
le monde qui s'incarnent à travers nos
parcours respectifs et aussi à travers
les idées et les propositions que l'on
porte et ça va aller très vite. Mais qui
est capable aujourd'hui d'organiser ce
débat ? Qui qui qui n'a pas peur
d'organiser ce genre de débat
aujourd'hui en France ? Nous, on veut
bien l'organiser et vous allez voir
comment ils vont le refuser. Vous savez
pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils ne tiennent que
parce que ces débats ne sont pas
organisés. C'est la seule chose qui leur
permet aujourd'hui d'apparaître comme
d'illusoire proposition politique.
Est-ce que vous avez suivi euh le DSA
européen ? De quoi ? Pardon ? Le DSA ?
DS, le Digital Service Act. Oui oui,
bien sûr. Est-ce que vous avez suivi les
dernières déclarations des différentes
plateformes auditionnées par notre Je me
demande même si c'est pas moi qui vous
les ai pas envoyé en premier quand je
les ai vu en commission parlementaire.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est euh
il y a un problème fondamental qui est
quand même est apparent depuis plus de
10 ans. On s'est beaucoup fiché de la
tête des des Chinois, des Russes, des
Iraniens qui avaient décidé d'essayer
d'autonomiser leur espace
informationnel. Alors évidemment, eux
ils le faisaient avant tout pour tenir
leur population mais la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous on est les derniers
dardons de la farce qui nous retrouvons
dépendant d'appareils de fabrication de
l'information qui sont étrangers.
Comment vous voulez prétendre être
souverain alors que votre système
fonctionne sur le vote, sur l'élection,
donc sur la participation des citoyens
de façon massive au choix des individus
qui vont les représenter et qu'en même
temps ce qu'ils vont savoir sur ces
individus est décidé à l'étranger.
Vous pensez vraiment que la France est
une puissance souveraine et le restera
dans des conditions comme celle-ci ? Et
alors le DSA, le DSA c'est juste une
tentative de construction d'une
paratutelle européenne qui légèrement
tente de faire contrepoids en fixant des
limites qui en fait ne conviennent qu'à
ceux qui sont déjà au pouvoir. Et on se
retrouve en fait dans une forme de
confusion assez assez délétaire où ceux
qui s'intéressent à la politique savent
qu'ils ne peuvent plus faire confiance
ni dans les algorithmes, ni évidemment
dans les médias traditionnels. Ça, on a
on a déjà purgé la question. Et ceux qui
ne s'y intéressent pas deviennent non
pas des êtres manipulés mais quand même
un peu, c'est-à-dire dirigé par des
affectes qui eux-mêmes sont décidés
entre Pékin et Palo Alto. Et au milieu
de tout ça, la France, c'est quoi la
France dans tout ça ? C'est pas
grand-chose en fait. J'en profite pour
dire à notre communauté, soutenez-nous
sur Tipi. C'est uniquement grâce à vous
qu'on peut produire des contenus quand
on veut, comme on veut, avec qui on
veut. C'est euh notre plus grande
liberté, c'est notre communauté et et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a choisi
de se financer via tipi et pas via la
Google monnaie ou la YouTube monnaie
pour être euh un peu immunisé euh de
tout ce qui pourrait être euh censuré,
anonymisé, ne pas être commandé ou des
choses comme ça et et on vous remercie
beaucoup pour ce soutien. Revenons à
notre interview. Ran,
les alliés potentiels à Aurore, c'est
qui ? Des des figures politique. En
fait, je sais pas si vous vous souvenez,
mais on a décidé de pirater le système
institutionnel français. C'estàd que
notre objectif, c'est pas d'avoir une
majorité parlementaire et ainsi de
suite. C'est par référendum de débloquer
les grands sujets euh de ce pays et du
coup de pouvoir courtcircuiter tous les
corps intermédiaires. Donc on aura pas à
composer avec euh la NASE qui est
devenue la classe politique française
actuelle. Notre objectif c'est d'ouvrir
les vannes grandes ouvertes et que tous
ceux qui auraient voulu s'engager et qui
n'ont jamais osé parce qu'ils sont dit
"Mais en fait tout ça est trop pourri ou
on va se faire détruire en de deux par
des oligarques ainsi de suite puisse
reprendre la place et puisse repeupler
l'espace." En fait on essaie de lutter
contre la médiocrisation du système
politique français. Vous voyez, c'est un
peu près ça. Et donc là encore autre
erreur de ma part, vous me prenez
peut-être un peu fatigué, c'est pour ça,
mais j'aurais même pas dû parler de
Dominique de Villepin. J'aurais même pas
dû parler de enfin voyez, il faut qu'on
sorte de ces dialectiques là qui nous
mettent en référence et en miroir que
avec des acteurs qui sont déjà installés
puisque notre objectif c'est d'ouvrir
les vannes. C'est vraiment de sortir de
de cette dynamique là. Et pour cela, il
va falloir survivre déjà. Enfin, il va
falloir constituer notre force
politique, mais il va falloir survivre
parce que je tiens à vous rappeler quand
même, je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
de le lendemain de notre avant-dernière
entre interview, j'avais reçu 170 pages
du barreau qui cherchait à me radier une
nouvelle fois et l'un des motifs pour
lesquels je voulais ramener quand même,
c'était le fait d'avoir écrit à une
procureur avec une enveloppe noire. Ce
qui, je cite le barreau, c'est dans ma
c'est dans mes 170 pages que je vous ai
amené
euh était susceptible d'exprimer une
approche hostile et inquiétante. Voyez
donc ça c'est un motif de tentative de
radiation de l'ordre des avocats à Paris
en sachant qu'il y a 38000 avocats à
Paris dont une grande partie sont
impliqués dans des activités qui ne sont
pas forcément très nettes qui peuvent
être légales notamment en droit des
affaires et ainsi de suite mais qui en
réalité consiste à corrompre escroquer
et ça c'est votre lecture. Bah oui, ça
c'est une lecture presque systémque de
ce qui est le droit des affaires en
France aujourd'hui et dans le monde en
général et donc 38000 avocats sans
procédure disciplinaires par an. Moi,
j'en suis à je sais plus c'est à 3e ou à
4e. Voyez, je m per mais et donc un des
quatre motifs sur demande du procureur
général de la cour d'appel de Paris,
c'est cette enveloppe noire qui du coup
est scannée, je vous ai ramené
l'original, vous voyez, elle est un peu
dégommée, en noir et blanc en disant
pièce à conviction numéro 1, pièce
numéro 1, il a écrit avec une enveloppe
noire. ce qu'ils oublient de de montrer
ou alors ce qui explique qui la scann en
noir et blanc
c'est qu'elle est doré c'est qu'en fait
c'est ma plus belle enveloppe du cabinet
que j'adresse au parquetier mais quand
vous êtes à un niveau de harcèlement qui
est similaire à ce que le FSB ou euh ou
le KGB pouvait mettre en place sous
l'Union soviétique c'est vraiment de on
essaie vraiment de déstabiliser avec
avec tris francs 6 sous c'est peut-être
ils sont peut-être aussi à il faut il
faut les il faut se mettre un peu à leur
Je comprends qu'ils soit accrversaires
sont accrants. Je comprends parce que on
c'est c'est c'est commun d'envoyer des
enveloppes noires. Alors nous nous on
aime bien le noir et blanc. Donc j'ai
des noirs, j'ai des bleus aussi hein.
Mais en l'occurrence le bleu c'est un
peu après il y a une petite phobie sur
le noir en France. Je sais pas à quoi
c'est lié mais mais de façon générale
mais je je pense que je vais arriver
devant le barreau en leur disant mais
quoi il faudrait que je commence à
plaider en robe blanche peut-être pour
pour ne pas inquiéter les procureurs.
C'est quoi le à quoi on joue en fait
quoi ? C'est quoi ? C'est quoi ? C'est
quoi la la dynamique dans laquelle vous
êtes en train de vous enfoncer vous-même
? On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Ça va bientôt faire 2h 1h47 et 20
secondes que nous sommes en direct.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
souhaiteriez aborder avec nous ? Moi, je
pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
il faut vraiment peut-être pas
maintenant, j'en sais rien, mais il faut
vraiment qu'on qu'on parle beaucoup
géopolitique au-delà des conflits
chauds. Donc, j'ai essayé d'exposer
notre position sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien, sur la question
ukrainienne, c'est évidemment
fondamental, mais il faut qu'il commence
à y avoir une vraie réflexion sur
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si la France
sortait de l'Union européenne. C'est un
vrai sujet parce que c'est une question
que les Français ont posé en 2005 en
s'opposant au traités qui avait été
adopté et qui n'est pas traité par nos
élites médiatiques, politique mais aussi
intellectuelle. Or, si on ne réfléchit
pas à ce que serait l'après, on peut pas
en créer une hypothèse qui à un moment
donné puisse être soumise au choix du
peuple français. Il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à nos relations avec le
Maghreb fondamental. N'oubliez pas qu'il
y a à peine plus de à moins de siècles,
il y avait encore des enlèvements
d'Occidentaux par des pirates dans qui
vivaient auprès du Bay d'Alger et des
esclaves occidentaux qui habit enfin
c'estd que on a de je vous donne cet
exemple pour dire de façon générale
on on est encore avec un cerveau qui du
fait de notre nature un peu
primitive fait qu'on a du mal à à
réajuster notre logiciel d'analyse. et à
se rendre compte que les puissances se
font et se défont très rapidement. Et
donc on continue à regarder avec
beaucoup de mépris euh des États et des
forces politiques qui sur le continent
africain, dans le Maghreb, sont en train
de prendre un ascendant beaucoup plus
important que ce que l'on pourrait le
penser et on continue à les traiter
comme si c'était des des moins que rien.
Et ça nous met en danger mais ça met
aussi en danger nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants. qu'on est en fait sur
une sur les perspectives de long terme
de la France, cette absence de de
compréhension de ce que l'on est plus
que l'on était il y a 40 50 ans que on
est encore dans un pays qui s'est
habitué à être la 2è ou la troisème
puissance mondiale économiquement
parlant comme elle l'a été dans les
années 60 et qui aujourd'hui doit subir
des concurrences y compris dans l'espace
méditerranéen avec la Turquie, avec la
Libye daftar, avec l'Algérie qui
commence à montrer des vél
de d'interventionnisme avec le Maroc qui
commence à avoir une influence très
importante notamment en Afrique en terme
de pour l'instant de politique de
médiation mais qui rapidement en fait
lui en train de donner une capacité à
agir sur un certain nombre de dirigeants
qui elle-même va lui donner une force
diplomatique majeure. C'est pas pour
rien qu'on a dû reconnaître la primauté
du Sara Occident, enfin du Maroc sur
Sarah occidental comme un chèque en
blanc sans sans rien obtenir en retour
et quit à nous mettre en difficulté
encore croissante avec l'Algérie. Et je
rappelle et c'est important qu'on dise
qu'il y a un journaliste français qui
vient d'être condamné à 13 ans de prison
en Algérie parce qu'il enquêtait sur le
football Kaby. Donc il y a Boem
Saint-Sal dont on a essayé de faire un
objet de division interne en France,
mais il y a aussi de façon croissante en
fait des tensions et une volonté de nous
faire payer le comportement d'un certain
nombre de nos dirigeants qui qui peut
provoquer des effets des effets sans
retour. Et donc à un moment donné quand
on a complètement perdu notre influence
au Liban, contrairement à ce qu' essayé
de prétendre et qu'on a pas du tout
reconstitué une politique
moyen-oriental,
moi je suis de la position que les États
du golf n'auraient jamais dû exister.
Pour vous donner un exemple, les États
du golfe sont une création
franco-anglaise
qui se qui visait en fait dans un moment
de décolonisation où il n'y avait plus
de capacité à maintenir une tutelle
directe sur des ressources pétrolifaires
et gazières visait à avoir des régimes
asservis qui parce que ils étaient à
nouveau là encore méprisés et semblaient
facilement contrôlables parce que on les
considérait comme comme étant des
incultes. complètement dépravés, ainsi
de suite, facilement
corruptible,
ont développé une puissance d'abord
économique et de façon croissante,
militaire, technologique et d'influence
qui est potentiellement et commence à
devenir concurrentiel. Ce qui se passe
dans le golf d'Aden, entre le golf
d'Aden et le D3 d'ormous au Yémen par
exemple, c'est quelque chose sur lequel
on a complètement perdu la main. On peut
s'agiter sur le fait que ce soit des
armes qui ont été vendues, des camions
César qui sont utilisés par l'Arabie
Saoudite et ainsi de suite ou l'Iran qui
donne l'autre côté de du conflit. La
réalité, voilà, c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui
des États que l'on considérait
complètement servil y a même pas encore
10 ans comme les Émirats arabes unis et
ainsi de suite qui aujourd'hui sont
devenus des puissances militaires et qui
sont en train de constituer une forme de
collier de perle de port. et qui vise à
avoir une forme d'hégémonie sur la
région dont on est en train d'être
évincé. Je vous rappelle que Jibouti il
y a 40 ans, la seule base militaire,
elle était française. Aujourd'hui, il y
en a six. Tout le monde s'y installé et
que notre base militaire est en train
d'être réduite à néant. Et à l'inverse,
on a les Émirats qui commencent à
installer le collier de perle, y
compris,
y compris, c'est très important que les
Français le sachent, y compris en
alliance avec Al-Qaïda contre les outils
et et l'Iran. C'estd que le sud Yémen
n'est tenu par un régime corrompu que
parce qu'on a des groupes terroristes
qui travaillent avec l'Arabie Saoudite
et les Émirats pour le contrôler. Et on
a des Ah bien sûr, il y a eu euh
nombreuses enquêtes notamment
d'associated de presse qui ont montré
cette forme de coopération affective
entre nos alliés qui s'autonomisent
progressivement de nous et des forces
terroristes que l'on présente fusil et
réellement détaillé comme étant voilà
nos nos principaux ennemis. C'estàd que
ce paradoxe là qu'on est en train de
revivre là en Syrie avec des
négociations entre la Syrie et Israël.
Qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer
entre la Syrie et Israël ? très
intéressant aussi la série. Là encore,
on a un rôle historique en série très
important qu'on a complètement saccagé
avec notre gestion du du conflit syrien
dont les Russes ont parfaitement profité
pour se créer un port dans la région
qu'ils ont dû évacuer récemment. Mais
donc pour tout ça étant dans quoi ? Dans
l'objectif de la prise de contrôle de
l'est de la Méditerranée. Vous voyez
c'est la la conflictualité. C'est pour
ça que je vous parlais Libye, Turquie,
Russie et notre et nous on ne regarde
jamais ces conflits. Nos dirigeants ne
regardent jamais ce ces conflits à
partir de nos intérêts stratégiques.
C'està-dire qu'on est dans une situation
soit de projection identitaire en ce qui
concerne le conflit israelopestinien,
soit de moralisme, soit euh de sorte de
néocolonialisme où on pense encore qu'on
est les maîtres du monde et que notre
position ce conflit israelopalestinien
va être celle qui va déterminer ce qui
va se passer sur le terrain. Et à côté,
on lâche complètement prise là où on en
avait encore pour essayer justement
d'essayer de constituer des modèles qui
à la libanaise fut f fut fut pouvait
correspondre à quelque chose qui qui
aujourd'hui n'existe plus. Et donc
quel est le sens aujourd'hui
fondamentalement
que l'on soit lié à Al-Qaïda, aux
Émirats et à l'Arabie Saoudite dont je
rappelle qu'il est dirigé par quelqu'un
qui a découpé un garçon en petit morceau
dans une ambassade euh c'est pas lui qui
l' fait qui l'a fait directement. Non
mais c'est lui qui l'a dirigé
directement. Et c'éit quoi le la musique
qu'ils avaient dans les oreilles déjà
Mais je me souviens par contre du selfie
que Macron a pris tout souriant avec
avec le commanditaire de cet assassinat
comme si tout cela n'était que c'était
Ah c'était Ouais. On a essayé de on a
essayé de de noyer ça avec son entourage
une sorte de mais non en réalité tout
tout porte à croire que c'était lui
directement. Mais qu'est-ce qui nous
rapproche civilisationnellement parlant
plus de l'Arabie Saoudite ? un régime
qui est de moins en moins wahabite mais
bon qui reste quand même très lié à à à
aux puissances religieuses
particulièrement radicales et
extrémistes de la région qui ont une
forme de sunisme. Donc je rappelle que
c'est son aspect conquérant qui a amené
à la mort sur le territoire français
avec le Bataclan et ainsi de suite. Et
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on a pas une
approche plus équilibrée à l'égard des
puissances cheites comme l'Iran, comme
une civilisation Perse qui a plusieurs
milliers d'années ? Parce qu'il faut
rappeler que il y a le régime, pas les
per, il y a le régime mais il y a la
société. Moi j'ai été en Iran. Moi, j'ai
vu cette société loin d'être aussi
caricaturelle qu'on la présente en 2018.
Euh donc pas si éloig de façon pas si
éloignée que ça. Qu'est-ce que vous
faisiez là-bas ? J'y suis allé visiter
le pays. Al en fait, c'est qui payait le
billet d'avion ? C'est moi et mon copain
qui était à l'époque à la direction du
trésor. On est parti un peu euh de façon
un peu inconsciente en en réalité. Euh
et on a passé 10 jours là-bas. On a on a
on a on a fait Téran et ainsi de suite.
On a rencontré un très proche ami qui
est aujourd'hui un un des plus grands
spécialistes de la région en France que
je vous recommande d'inviter qui a écrit
un très beau texte Alexandre Caseroni
sur la situation en Iran et sur les
dangers de cette volonté de changement
de régime qui était porté par Netaniahou
non seulement évidemment pour la pour
pour les Iraniens mais pour la région
dans son ensemble. quelqu'un qui est
loin loin d'être évidemment d'une
quelque forme que ce soit assimilable au
régime des mola. Il est pas mola au
lâtre. Vous savez ce que j'ai vu en en
Iran, j'ai vu des gens faire des
pèlerinages pour aller sur des tombes de
poètes. Sur des tombes de poètes.
D'accord. C'est une société qui a un
ancrage historique qui fait de nous les
Français des petits ploues. D'accord ?
Enfin, si on s'inscrit dans la durée
longue, la civilisation perse par
rapport à une quelconque civilisation
européenne, c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est d'une ampleur toute
différente. Et cette civilisation, elle
existe. pas parce qu'aujourd'hui elle a
une orientation politique euh et
religieuse qui va dans une certaine
direction euh que euh et d'ailleurs la
preuve c'est que contrairement à ce qui
a été le cas de façon euh très objective
parce que j'aime beaucoup
l'instrumentalisation de la cause de la
femme par les géopolitiques en herbe et
ainsi de suite euh quand il s'agissait
d'éviter les violences commises contre
les femmes en Arabie Saoudite y compris
les coups de foie y compris le hijab
intégral et ainsi de suite euh ça
discutait pas beaucoup en Iran
C'est pas pour relativiser mais ils ont
des femmes quand même. Ils ont pendu des
gens
en Iran. Les J'ai jamais vu des femmes
aussi apprêtées portant le voile parfois
ici dans la rue sans aucune difficulté
qu'en Iran. Euh quand vous prenez un
taxi en Iran, euh un taxi sur deux va
vous dire tout le mal qu'il pense du
régime pour une raison très simple. le
PIB a été divisé par 2 en plus en ces 10
dernières années à cause notamment des
sanctions qui ont été appliquées à leur
égard et parce que le régime considère
que sa survie est plus importante
que le développement économique du pays.
Mais tout cela génère un peu des effets
similaires à la catastrophe qu'a été le
franquisme en Espagne. C'estàd qu'en
fait la société comme elle est isolée du
reste du monde préserve une différence.
C'est le seul endroit au monde où j'ai
été dépaysé, où j'ai ressenti dans le
rapport aux gens, dans dans la
fonctionnement de la société quelque
chose de différent de ce qu'on voit dans
le reste du monde. Vous voyez, c'est
déjà allé en Inde bien sûr, j'ai vécu en
Inde. J'ai vécu en Inde à Comment on dit
bonjour en Indie ? Je me souviens plus.
Comment on dit merci ? Namasté.
Vous êtes sûr ? Non, je me souviens
plus. Dites-moi, non, je pas de cours
d'indiy aujourd'hui. Hop, cassé he Et
donc,
j'ai vécu à Savdardiang enclave à New
Delhi pendant 4 mois quand j'avais 20
ans. Euh, j'étais pas paradis,
c'était mon année d'échange quand
j'étais à Sciencep et je me suis
retrouvé pour un un tableoïde à faire
les petits événements mondins de de
l'élite New Delhi. Et en fait, j'étais
avec des gens qui ne parlaient parce que
les qui ne parlaient que que indie, qui
ne parlaient pas anglais parce que les
photographes, j'étais photographe, je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris mais c'était
une époque où j'aimais beaucoup l'image.
Euh les euh les euh les les anglais
enfin pardon, les les photographes
étaient considérés comme étant euh en
gros d'une condition sociale inférieure
au gardiens d'immeubles et compagnie.
Donc on avait pas les gens ne venaient
pas leur parler du coup ne venaient pas.
Donc j'ai vécu 4 mois en autarsie
complète sans rien comprendre à ce qui
m' arrivait et viceversa dans une forme
de de d'étrangeté qui qui m'a beaucoup
marqué et et d'ailleurs ça m'a beaucoup
marqué parce que j'avais j'avais
l'impression que j'en avais tiré c'est
que
l'Inde avait justement gardé ses
soubassements civilisationnels
contrairement à la Chine qui se les
avait fait dévast à travers l'aventure
communiste qui est en train d'arriver à
sa fin. Mais mais pour revenir à l'Iran,
ce que je suis en train de dire est
fondamental pour une raison parce que
euh
Hamenei aujourd'hui,
c'est pas grand-chose de plus qu'un
boutalfik pour Alger. Quand on voit euh
quand il fait ses dernières
interventions médiatiques,
euh il est gravataire. Or, le
renouvellement du régime iranien va être
très compliqué. les nouvelles élites,
les nouveaux les nouvelles générations
qui se sont beaucoup enrichis grâce au
gardiens de la révolution ainsi de suite
se comporte en prédateur et en pilleur.
Et on voit en fait dans Terran, on avait
vu dans Terran des lieux de nouveau
riches un peu multipliés à l'occidental
paradoxalement où il faisait
démonstration de leur pouvoir et de la
racise. Question internet. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de l'ancien chat d'Iran
Mohamed Reza et du travail de
développement assez conséquent qu'il a
sur rééaliser à l'époque ? Bah ce que je
sais c'est que la population en est en
était si peu satisfaite qu'on a quand
même eu euh euh
l'opposant
Romaini qui était quand même en exilence
en France s'allié avec la gauche y
compris marxiste pour les sortir de là.
tant la corruption et les fastes de ce
régime avait fini par alasser les
populations locales et donc là penser
que le fils qui n'a évidemment aucun
ancrage dans la société iranienne serait
de nature à c'est que s'ils avaient été
intelligents, s'ils étaient un minimum
fin, ils seraient allés chercher au sein
de l'opposition qui existe aujourd'hui,
au sein de ce régime. Voyez, il y a
beaucoup de personnalités qui sont soit
en disgrâce, soit non, ils vont ils vont
chercher sorte de de fabrication
quelqu'un qui a quand même déclaré qu'
qu'il voudrait rester une partie du
temps en dehors de l'Iran s'il revenait
au pouvoir parce qu'en fait sa vie est
est ailleurs. Donc on est dans la
situation mais mais c'est important ce
que je vous dis sur les soubassements
civilisationnels et ce qui ce qui a été
préservé malgré les évolutions des
régimes et ainsi de suite. Vous avez eu
raison de parler de l'Inde parce que je
pense que l'Inde sur le long terme a une
assise beaucoup plus solide que la Chine
qui par ailleurs est en train de
vieillir à une vitesse la la Chine a le
même âge moyen que la France quasiment.
on est à 42, ils sont à 40 et quelques.
Or, le le le niveau de capital
disponible et par par rapport à à ce que
vous décrivez visuellement là en face de
la pyramide des âges euh va rendre très
très compliqué la transition auquelle on
va être confronté et rend très inquiet
le régime en place. Très très inquiet.
D'autant plus que vous avez quasiment
euh 200 millions de personnes, donc une
grande partie de la population active,
177 millions euh dans mon souvenir qui
n'ont pas le passeport intérieur.
C'est-à-dire que on leur a on les a
autorisé de facto à migrer,
mais ils n'ont pas le droit d'acquérir
des biens
dans les villes où ils sont. Et donc ils
économisent énormément, ils tésorisent
mais ils ne participent pas à l'activité
économique et ils n'arrivent pas à faire
monter socialement euh leurs enfants. Et
donc soit il y a une transition assez
rapide avec une formez les conséquences
énormes. Vous aurez tout d'un coup un
déversement de personn de capital qui
pourrait produire de grands dangers et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils y soient prêt.
Donc on a la Chine qui par ailleurs a
détruit une grande partie de ses
fondements civilisationnels et on a un
côté l'Inde. Quand vous vivez en Inde,
vous comprenez à quel point la question
d'un pays en développement peut
s'incarner, quoi. C'est compliqué hein,
c'est très désorganisé, ainsi de suite,
mais qui a préservé, y compris à travers
plus du tout le même système de cast
qu'à l'époque, mais qui continue encore
à produire des effets assez sévères sur
la société et qui en fait joue
paradoxalement un facteur stabilisant.
stabilisant qui fait que par rapport au
sous-bresseau économiques, par rapport
aux difficultés que justement leur
absence de dirigisme similaire à celui
de de la Chine peuvent produire et bien
se retrouve dans une position euh de
force mais sur le long terme à mon sens
euh à condition qu'ils arrivent à sortir
peut-être de l'hypothèse body que que
mon cher Emmanuel Macron a a tant aimé.
Le le médecin qui m'a soigné en au Congo
était indien.
Donc euh très très éduqué puisque devenu
médecin là-bas et ainsi de suite et il
avait un discours quasi génocidaire à
l'égard des musulmans. C'était très
intéressant en fait le discours de
Maudit. Maudit a permis une
radicalisation mais massive de la
population indienne sur les questions
identitaires et sur
la séparation identitaire entre hindou
et musulman qui d'ailleurs commence à se
concrétiser dans les tensions qu'on l'on
a vu avec le avec le Pakistan qui est
particulièrement révélatrice. Et il
avait ce mot et il disait "Mais vous
savez vous les Européens vous souvrez
pas tant que vous aurez réglé le
problème musulman." Donc il s'inscrivait
dans une perspective de guerre de
civilisation à l'échelle mondiale
et et ça c'est aujourd'hui maudit,
c'est-à-dire c'est le principal allié
que c'est choisi Emmanuel Macron dans la
zone indo-acifique.
Est-ce que vous avez d'autres sujets que
vous souhaiteriez aborder avec nous ? En
tout cas, je tenais à ce qu'on parle de
de ces questions là qu'on aurait pu
développer si ça vous intéressait et je
regrette presque on on avait pas parlé
en début au début parce que ça faisait
longtemps que je voulais qu'on prenne ce
temps parce que encore une fois, il faut
aussi que que les Français comprennent
que les alternatives demain vont se
jouer aussi sur le regard qu'on a sur le
monde et notre capacité à proposer des
des politiques différentes qui qui
exigent des des ruptures sérieuses. Vous
voyez ? Et pour ça, il faut une clé de
voûte. Il faut une clé de lecture, un
prisme de lecture. Faut du
renseignement, faut avoir des dans les
capacités d'être dans la capacité de
faire de la prospective et il faut ne
pas détruire les personnes qui au sein
de sa société essayent de réfléchir de
cette façon. beaucoup de gens parfois à
force de me voir dans des aventures
toutes plus extravagantes les unes que
les autres finissent par oublier
pourquoi est-ce que on peut présenter un
danger structurel à l'égard d'un certain
nombre de puissances politiques et ainsi
de suite. Et je pense que c'est pour ça
que c'était important de prendre le
temps de faire ces développements d'une
part parce que c'est important de les
partager et de faire réfléchir et de
réfléchir avec les personnes qui vont
nous regarder mais aussi de
contextualiser de montrer qu'on on n'est
pas l'animal médiatique et social qu'on
qu'on presque mondin qu'on cherche à
construire. En fait, la valeur que l'on
a et la valeur qu'à tout être humain,
elle se constitue sur l'accumulation de
savoir et sur la capacité en fait à un
moment donné du coup peu à peu produire
des déplacements par rapport au réel qui
nous permettent
de construire un monde meilleur. Je vous
vois un peu distrait, je sais pas ce que
vous faites. Non, on était en train de
regarder les questions sur internet.
Est-ce qu'il y avait des questions à
gauche à droite ? On a eu un petit
problème de rafraîchissement de page
pour rentrer dans le détail, mais c'est
dû à la chaleur. On était pas censé
tourner aujourd'hui.
Pour rentrer un peu dans le secret des
dieux, quand vous êtes sorti de notre
interview et qu'on a appris votre
vos petits soucis à Kinshasa,
on a activé nos antennes et on a activé
nos nos yeux et nos oreilles un peu
partout pour avoir des
nouvelles de vous toutes les 12h de
plusieurs sources et y compris des
sources de première main et parce qu'on
était relativement inquiet et on l'
toujours à votre égard et C'est pour ça
que on est très content d'avoir ce petit
débrief.
On va vous inviter et vous réinviter
pour la nouvelle saison qui commencera
au mois de septembre. Avec le plaisir.
On fera un
petit point sur ce qui se passe et on
essaiera de de creuser plus les
questions de géopolitique, plus des
questions de prisme de lecture, de
trajectoire, de cap. Comment vous allez
pouvoir avoir une architecture pour
pouvoir réaliser ce cap ?
Bon vous entourez, qui vous entourez ?
Et avec plaisir, d'autant plus que vous
savez il y a un de vos invités qui a un
jour sur cette chaîne m'avait envoyé un
petit message euh qui s'appelait Dou
Plenel et vous lui avez posé une
question à mon sujet, il avait répondu,
je me souviens plus de la phrase exacte,
mais quelque chose comme
on ne
qui était un message implicite et
d'ailleurs, il a concrétisé quelques
mois plus tard, mais qui consistait à
dire "On ne survit pas seul." Enfin, en
gros, euh euh
parce qu'il considérait quelque part que
j'étais trop intransigent à l'égard d'un
certain nombre d'alliés potentiel dont à
l'époque lui et Miapart et et de façon
un peu misquine, il s'en vengerait
quelques mois plus tard et et je pense
qu'il a il avait tort et raison. C'estàd
je pense que mon intransigence était
légitime, elle m'a beaucoup coûté y
compris face à des alliés. Je pense que
j'avais j'étais un des premiers à
prévenir sur quelques tendances que
François Ruffin avait à ne pas être à la
hauteur des espérance qu'on pouvait
placer sur lui. J'ai payé très cher
d'avoir prévenu sur le côté sombre d'une
partie de la direction d'anticorps à un
moment donné. Vous voyez, c'est des
gestes qui sont compliqués parce que
vous êtes déjà face à des puissances
extraordinaires et il y a quelques
points d'appui potentiel et ou au
minimum de neutralité et c'est votre
lecture sur corps et pointé. Ça a été
vraiment euh étayé de façon D'ailleurs,
vous avez reçu la personne qui a révélé
ça, c'était Maxime Renai, enfin les
compromissions qu'il y avait eu à
l'époque. Vous avez aussi reçu euh des
dirigeants, voilà. Mais euh mais euh on
les recevra aussi pour la nouvelle
culture. Voilà. Mais mais ça a été euh
ça a été étayé et en fait ça vaut pas
condamnation de l'ensemble de façon
défise. Si ça vaut pas condamnation, ça
vaut rien. Non non, je veux dire, ça
vaut pas condamnation d'anticorps en
tant qu'ent. C'est c'est pas parce qu'à
un moment donné un être humain se trompe
de chemin voire comme une erreur ou une
faute que pour autant il faut
l'oblitérer. Voyez, ça c'est quand même
fondamental. Mais par contre euh il faut
être sans trans il ne faut pas transiger
à l'égard de ses proches et de ses
alliés parce que c'est ce qui nous
protège de la défaillance et ce qui nous
protège du fait de devenir ceux à qui on
s'oppose. Et si et j'ai appris ces
dernières années à faire une distinction
fondamentale entre ceux qui sont dans ce
jeu pour le pouvoir et qui pour le
pouvoir sont prêts à toutes les
compromissions, sont prêts à toutes les
C'est pour ça encore une fois que par
exemple sur Rimassan, je reste très
dans l'acceptation parce qu'en fait je
vois que fondamentalement ce qui se joue
est très intime chez cette personne à
l'égard de son parcours politique. Il y
a quelque chose qui qui ne peut qu'être
sincère quelque part même si ensuite il
peut y avoir des dérives, des erreurs ou
qu'on peut être en désaccord fondamental
avec elle. Il y en a d'autres qui ne
rentrent là-dedans que par névrose, que
par recherche de pouvoir, que par
recherche d'argent. Euh parce que
l'information est un est une ressource,
est quelque chose qui se trafique. Ça
c'est très important que les Français
euh le sachent et que vos auditeurs le
savent déjà. Euh euh il y a très peu
d'acteurs sur la scène euh publique
française qui n'interviennent pas au
service d'intérêt, y compris leur leur
directement parce qu'ils en tirent des
bénéfices. Et donc euh trouver quelques
points d'appui qui restent relativement
distancé par rapport à ces influences,
par rapport à ces tentatives de
corruption, d'absorption et ainsi de
suite. C'est une respiration
fondamentale. Dieu sait que c'est dur et
Dieu sait comme ils sont peu nombreux.
Et donc je suis je suis content de me
retrouver parfois dans des espaces où
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quelque
chose là qui est pas de l'ordre de la
pureté, qui est simplement de l'ordre de
de la naturalité. Vous voyez, c'est on
est on n'est pas au service de quelque
chose, on est là simplement. Rien que
ça, c'est déjà quelque chose parce que
nous on est des sparciates au service de
notre communauté
et on est prêt à nous faire aucun
sacrifice et de la France, j'espère. Ah
bah bien entendu
la question ne se pose même pas. Ran
Brancou, est-ce que vous avez trois
livres à conseiller à notre communauté ?
Bah dis donc, à force, je vais je vais
finir par vider ma ma bibliothèque. Euh
je peux vous proposer Ce n'est que la 4e
fois que vous passez depuis 2017. C'est
vrai. Mais dont dont trois sur la
dernière année et demi, je pense. Non,
mais là aujourd'hui, c'était nécessaire
mais je trouve ça je trouve je pense que
ce serait émouvant de voir celle de fait
40°gr dans le Ouais. studio, je commence
un peu à et et euh mais mais ça serait
peut-être bien de voir celle de 2017
parce que j'avais quel âge quand même ?
J'avais 28 ans. Vous avez pas beaucoup
changé ? Vous êtes toujours aussi beau
garçon ? Je pour moi c'était une
éternité cette période he parce que en
fait j'ai pourquoi ça serait bien parce
que j'entrais la fleur au fusil euh avec
mon petit crépuscule là où balancer
quelques scudes. Non, c'était au moment
je pense de c'était au moment Ah non non
non. 2017 en effet. Oui oui c'est
justement c'est 2 ans avant. Je suis
encore euh jeune avocat de Wikileaks où
je viens de le devenir jeune avocat de
Wikileaks et et de quelques autres mais
très peu. Je suis là euh je suis en
enjeu pour personne. Donc en fait il y a
une forme de de naïveté complètement
délirante. Et et si j'avais dit à ce à
ce gamin euh ce que ça allait être et où
on en serait 8 ans plus tard, mais
j'aurais eu du mal en fait alors même
que j'avais été confronté à ce que déjà
avait vécu Julian Nassange. Enfin je
l'avais vu de près, voyez, la folie de
ce monde. Mais il y a toujours cette
sorte de chos qui vous dit ça m'arrivera
pas. Enfin, voyez, moi euh bon, je suis
pas et puis puis c'est vrai qu'on a pas
la même importance, voyez. Et puis peu à
peu les choses évoluent et euh et c'est
vrai qu'après il y a eu crépuscule par
contre le deuxè. Et là, et là et là
pareil, je pense qu'il y avait encore
une forme de naïveté un peu un peu
sidérante mais importante parce que je
pense que ça a servi beaucoup de gens et
je pense que ça a permis de participer à
une reconfiguration de l'espace
politique français qui est encore en
cours. C'estàd qu'en fait les effets
sous-jacents de la révélation de l'effet
de structure des alliances entre
oligarques pour fabriquer des des des
candidats euh en annonçant quand même
Gabriatal des années avant qu'il
devienne quelqu'un et ainsi de suite.
qu'en confirmant que ce qui était dit
sur Macron n'était pas juste le fruit
d'un coup de chance mais enfin le fruit
d'une analyse structurelle et que donc
ça avait un intérêt. Ça ça leur a fait
ça leur a fait très mal et ça nous a
donné à tous collectivement beaucoup de
pouvoir et vous avez contribué largement
parce que je pense que ça fait 5
millions de vues. C'estàd que ceux qui
n'ont pas forcément le rapport à la
lecture et au livre comme vous ne cessez
de le recommander à chaque fois ont pu
avoir accès quand même à un substrat de
ce qui était de ce qui était raconté.
Donc ça c'est un c'est quelque chose
d'assez miraculeux et même si
aujourd'hui vous êtes shadow ban et même
si cet entretien finit par ne faire que
200 300000 vues ainsi de suite ça
restera voyez ce et puis on est en train
de laisser des petites traces. Partagez
cette vidéo partagez nos vidéos,
commentez envoyez ça sur toutes vos
plateformes. Il faut qu'on arrive à et
ayez conscience de votre pouvoir. En
fait toutes ces portes qu'on a ouvertes
au Fick elles le reste. Ils ont pas
réussi. Ils ont réussi éventuellement.
C'est mon avis sur l'ouverture des
portes au Fick. Oui, mais mais je vous
en ai rendu complice sans vous en rendre
compte. On a peut-être on a on a on a on
a on a ils ont peut-être réussi à à
moindrir et à fragiliser les individus.
La violence c'est la force des faibles
et commence où s'arrête les
connaissances. Ouais. Mais la violence
est omniprésente dans la société. Ça
aussi c'est très important. Il ne faut
jamais utiliser les armes de l'ennemi.
Mais elle est vous savez que la violence
elle est dans tous les rapports sociaux
et que et que il faut faire très très
attention à ne pas engénérer soi-même
sans se rendre compte. Et en même temps,
il faut faire très attention et ça
c'était ma grande erreur parce que
j'étais sur votre position en me disant
entre le deuxème et le 3è viw. Si vous
vous désarmez,
vous faites massacrer parce qu'il y a
des gens mauvais dans la société. Il
faut jamais l'oublier. Il y a des gens
mauvais et euh la position christique,
la position qui consiste à dire tendre
l'autre jour n'est pas une position
politique. Elle vous fait féconder des
nouveaux ordres spirituels, mais elle
vous fait détruire individuellement en
tant que corps et aussi en tant
qu'alternative politique à court terme
parce que ils sont sans pitié en face,
ils se lavent les mains. C'est ça la
leçon du des évangiles. Donc à un moment
donné, il faut avoir une posture
défensive de haut niveau. haut niveau
qui consiste à dire tu tu tu faites
attention parce que si vous venez pour
nous massacrer des conséquences pour
intervenir. Donc c'est pas si évident
que ça vous voyez il faut trouver
l'équilibre et c'est un peu le but de la
refondation d'un pays qui
s'est emporté dans des aventures qui
n'étaient pas forcément dignes de son
histoire et qui doit maintenant doit
retrouver un équilibre
à partir d'une position qui doit être de
non agression a priori. trois livres
pour notre communauté et un conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Moi, je pense qu'il faut absolument euh
lire de la poésie, ce qui est pas
facile. Euh donc euh des exemples, je je
pensais à un exemple, un auteur allemand
pour être écuménique. Rilque Rilque RE,
c'est quelque chose d'accessible et
d'une légèreté et d'une beauté vraiment
phénoménale, y compris dans cette
traduction, ce qui est ce qui est très
compliqué à à
parfois à traduire cette beauté du
français quand même un peu.
Moi, je pense qu'il faut euh en fait, il
faut s'astreindre à des lectures. Euh
euh par exemple, j'ai beaucoup lu euh
ces derniers temps, l'été dernier,
l'été, racine. Et alors encore une fois,
c'est compliqué de lire Racine quand on
a essayé de se infliger de enfin quand
on se l' vu infliger à l'école, qu'on
nous l'a fait appréhendre par cœur,
qu'on comprenait pas pourquoi on nous
parlait de Britanni Cus, de Titus, de je
sais pas quoi. Bon, toutes ces et toutes
ces toutes ces mythes qui sont chaque
fois plus éloignés de des fondements de
notre société actuelle. Alors, je
recommande juste une chose. Vous
téléchargez un des derniers miracles qui
a généré l'État français, c'est Radio
France, pas France Inter. Vous allez
télécharger l'application, vous allez
sur l'appli Radio France, vous allez sur
France Culture, vous tapez non, vous
tapez juste sur la barre de recherche de
l'application, tapez Racine. Et là, vous
avez les enregistrements de la Comédie
française des 60, des 70. Vous avez des
gens qui pendant des décennies ont fait
l'effort de rendre accessible à des gens
qui n'avaient pas forcément le temps,
l'énergie de lire et ainsi de suite des
œuvres qui sont fondamentales pour
comprendre non seulement pour sédimenter
la langue française parce que c'est
c'est à ce moment-là que se sédimente la
langue française après les premiers
efforts de
de Rabblé et ainsi de suite qui euh Oh
là là, la fatigue, c'est catastrophique,
les poètes de la Playade, pardon, on y
arrive. Mais aussi parce que qu'est-ce
que fait racine ? J'ai découvert ça en
les écoutant en boucle et après en les
lisant. Il prend la mythologie grecque
et il fait disparaître les dieux.
Si vous lisez Racine par rapport à ce
socle et ainsi de suite, vous découvrez
que c'est le drame réduit à l'humain.
C'est-à-dire que toute c'est la tragédie
mais sans sans plus les délibérations
entre les différents les différents
dieux qui qui s'engueulent au sujet des
humains et ainsi de suite, vous
retrouvez juste avec la chair humaine
qui est la proie de la tragédie. Et rien
que pour comparer, parce qu'on a tous
fait un peu de mythologie grecque même
si on a arrêté l'école d'eau, comparer
entre
moi je trouve que c'est un sujet
fascinant. On devrait tous réfléchir à
qu'est-ce qui fait que au 17e siècle en
France, d'une part, on décide d'aller
chercher tous les mythes de la Grèce
antique et qu'à un moment donné, celui
qui va devenir l'auteur le plus
important de notre temps et de notre
langue en tout cas va décider de
reproduire ce mythe
sans avoir un quelconque dieu dedans,
mais juste avec les mêmes personnages
par contre qui vont s'entredéchirer, se
tuer, mourir, antigon. Donc donc ça
c'est ça c'est vraiment c'est
passionnant. Et puis la langue, c'est ce
qui vous protège de la violence
des dominants. La compréhension. La
compréhension, mais aussi la maîtrise de
l'instrument. la capacité à ne pas se
faire humilier parce qu'on ne
détiendrait pas ce code et de pouvoir
tenir face à quelqu'un qui parce qu'il
aurait fait des études ou juste aurait
grandi dans un milieu bourgeois pourrait
vous mépriser parce que il y a un moment
donné des termes que vous ne comprenez
pas ou des formules que c'est c'est
votre meilleure façon de prendre le
poignard pour attaquer et abattre celui
qui vous voudrait c'est pas prendre le
poignard c'est prendre la plume.
Et c'est quoi prendre la plume et la
tremper dans la plie ? Voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera impér
impérissable pendant que nous on va
conseiller l'art d'avoir toujours raison
d'Arthur Schopenhauer qui est un de ses
moins bons livres. Par contre le monde
le le monde comme représentation est
excellent. Ça c'est le troisème livre
que je recommande du coup. Le monde
comme représentation. Lisez les 15
premières pages de Chopen. C'est c'est
un bouquin de 600 pages. Euh vous lisez
les 15 premières pages si vous voulez
vous friterz un peu avec avec de la
philosophie. Alors là, vous prenez ça
déjà, ça va prendre du temps, vous lisez
à voix haute autant de fois que
nécessaire, mais à un moment donné, vous
confrontez à la beauté sublime des
concepts qu'il vous proposent. C'est
soit ça, soit du nichez pour vous amuser
euh sur de la pensée philosophique un
peu politique. Mais Chopenhauer, c'est
c'est assez impressionnant et et ça
devient très vite jouissif, mais il faut
prendre le temps une fois, deux fois,
trois fois parce que ça en audiobook euh
c'est très bien s'endormir avec et euh
et euh Oui, voilà, c'est ça exactement
vous si si nécessaire, mais il faut que
ce soit les versions intégrales. Vous
vous laissez pas avoir par les euh par
les nombreuses et euh et s'il vous plaît
ces auteurs-là euh puis enfin, il faut
les télécharger gratuitement quoi.
Enfin, c'est c'est pour ça que je
recommande l'appli de Radio France parce
que c'est archives qui sont là à
disposition de tous. Conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Et moi je pense mon ami Ranien, je vous
en parlais parce que à un moment donné
avec toute cette phase mit tout
d'hystérisation des rapports entre les
hommes et les femmes m'a dit mais à un
moment donné j'ai eu l'impression de
commencer à découvrir parce queon parle
beaucoup encore une fois des mots comme
l'antitheste. J'ai j'ai l'impression de
me retrouver à nouveau en Iran. ce côté
où en fait les mœurs devenaient un
instrument d'ostracisation, de
destruction de l'autre, de règlement de
compte et ainsi de suite. Et là, j'ai
l'impression que la société est en train
de se détendre un peu par rapport à ça.
On a compris en fait qu'on avait une
phase
quand même, il y a la les violences
sexuelles resteront omniprésentes dans
la société, il faut toujours se battre
contre elle. Mais il y a il faut
comprendre que quels instruments on
utilise pour se battre, voyez. et la
justice avant la justice euh
l'utilisation de l'espace public comme
moyen de régler des comptes même
l'utilisation de de l'institution
judiciaire qui est comme l'utilisation
de l'espace médiatique peut-être voilà
mais ou judiciaire qui est très mal
armée pour euh aller dans l'intimité des
gens voyez un un juge d'instruction euh
le conseil pour les jeunes génération
donc aimer aimer et la la précieusité du
désir la précieusité du rapport à
l'autre qui soit sans angoisse sans
arrière-pensé sans sans inquiétude
reconstruire une société où il soit
possible de purger les blessures qui ont
amené à cette panique morale parce qu'il
faut jamais juger les paniques morales.
C'est un peu, il faut toujours essayer
de comprendre d'où elles viennent.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que tout d'un coup
une société entière, une génération
entière s'est sentie vulnérable à
l'égard de l'autre y compris dans son
intimité ? C'est ça qui compte parce que
cette génération n'était pas plus
exposée à la violence sexuelle que les
précédentes. Plutôt l'inverse. Les
précédentes, vous imaginez bien avec le
patriarcat, tout ce qu'on pourrait dire
des 70 80, il y avait une sorte de ce
qui s'est joué à mon avis, c'est plus de
l'ordre du traumatisme par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé ces dernières années, y
compris politiquement avec la crise de
2008, l'impossibilité de se construire,
d'avoir un logement dans la ville, de
pouvoir fonder une famille et ainsi de
suite. Et tout ça généré une violence
horizontale. Et la question c'est et
pour pouvoir aimer, qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire ? Il va falloir reconstruire cette
société. Il va falloir changer les
choses aussi politiquement. C'est là où
il faut faire le lien entre différentes
Je finis vraiment sur cette donnée.
J'avais déjà énoncé la dernière fois
mais il faut il faut que je la répète.
La multiplication par 8 des
hospitalisations pour tentative de
suicide chez les jeunes femmes entre 15
et 25 ans. Qu'est-ce que ça dit d'une
société ? Qu'est-ce que ça dit d'une
société ? Où est-ce que où est-ce que
nous sommes tous en train d'échouer
collectivement de sorte qu'on a cet
accroissement des violences
extraordinaires ? Je parle des jeunes
femmes et les hommes, les jeunes hommes
qui se suicident. beaucoup plus que les
jeunes femmes. Donc on a une explosion
du des tentatives de suicide chez les
jeunes femmes et on a un niveau
extraordini élevé de suicide effectif
chez les hommes qui pour une raison ou
une autre ont peut-être un rapport à la
violence plus facilité à cause de de
facteurs sociaux, hormonaux, tout ce
qu'on voudra et ainsi de suite, y
compris vis-à-vis d'eux-même. Et donc,
on est sur une gangraine qui elle-même
pour le coup génère derrière des
violences sexuelles, des violences
conjugales et ainsi de suite dont le
traitement doit être avant tout
politique. politique toutes ces
questions et il faut qu'on réfléchisse à
nouveau sur qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on a
une société où on peut plus construire
des familles où on peut plus vivre dans
les villes où on est censé travailler où
on peut plus à un moment donné se
retrouver dans un rapport d'émancipation
individuelle mais dans une angoisse
collective qui est en train de nous
amener à la destruction et à la
dévastation. Ran Branco, merci. Merci à
vous.
[Musique]